Okay.
Moin, Leute.
Was habe ich verpasst?
Die Woche war bestimmt einiges los,
aber ich habe nichts davon mitgekriegt.
Sind wieder irgendwelche Internetknotenpunkte
ausgefallen, Clouds
abgekackt oder sonst was?
Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Ich glaube, es...
Was sagst du dazu, dass die Amis Frankfurt
aufräumen wollen?
Keine Ahnung.
Wollen sie?
Das...
Die US Army patrouilliert
an deutschem Bahnhof.
Seit wann hat der eigentlich
so kurze Haare?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich wusste nicht, dass die Amis am Hauptbahnhof
sind in Frankfurt.
Aber...
Ich meine, wirklich machen können die ja nichts,
außer da rumlaufen.
Aus dem Laufen da bestimmt schon genug rum.
Wobei, rumpatrouillieren...
Eher nicht.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht.
Laut, ja?
Leute, ich war halt schon...
Rennen.
Ich bin neun...
Ich bin 7.15 Uhr aufgestanden.
7.20 Uhr so in dem Dreh.
Mülli, danke schön für den Zap.
Dann war ich 45 Minuten Rennen.
So bis...
Also, ich habe jetzt was gegessen.
Bin 7.45 Uhr, bin ich glaube ich raus.
Dann war ich Rennen.
Dann war ich 8.30 Uhr ungefähr wieder da.
Dann habe ich noch kurz Zeug umgezogen.
Bin an den Rechner.
Hab Rechner angemacht, beide.
Streaming, Vorschau, Rechner.
Und hab angeworfen.
Ja.
Also ich schaffe jetzt relativ konstant
6 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer.
Über 6 Kilometer.
Meine Standardstrecke ist so 6,07, 6,1.
So je nachdem, auf welcher Straßenseite ich laufe.
Das packe ich relativ konstant jetzt.
Wobei ich das nicht jedes Mal laufe.
Heute hatte ich auch wohl nicht so viel Zeit.
Und ich sage es euch, heute hatte ich auch nur...
Bin ich extra mal ein bisschen langsamer gerannt.
Ich glaube heute hatte ich 7 Minuten 20 oder sowas.
Weil man kann es ja nicht immer total übertreiben.
Das ist ja auch blöde.
Wenn man es immer voll übertreibt.
Dann hat man irgendwann keinen Bock mehr.
So wirklich springen tut es wahrscheinlich auch nichts.
Also heute 6,1 Kilometer.
Ja, 7 Minuten 39.
Pro Kilometer heute.
Dafür nur 148 Puls im Durchschnitt.
Ja.
Also langsam geht es echt gut.
Muss ich sagen.
Moin.
Langsam geht es echt gut.
Ich glaube das schnellste, was ich je hatte.
Also das schnellste, was ich bisher hatte war.
Jetzt misst der Zähl.
Irgendwie 6,27 oder so.
Für die 6,1 Kilometer.
Also nicht für die...
Also pro Kilometer über 6,1 Kilometer.
Und...
Da wäre sicherlich noch ein bisschen was gegangen.
Aber ich muss ja wieder heimkommen.
Bringt ja nichts, wenn ich mit Zwischendrehen voll im Arsch bin.
Und nicht mehr zurückkomme.
Also was ich unbedingt mal machen muss.
Ich muss mal auf irgendeinen Sportplatz hier.
Mit so einer Bahn.
Drumherum.
Und muss mal wirklich.
Da kontrolliert mit Pulsgurt.
Und so rennen.
Dass ich mal weiß, was mein maximaler Puls ist.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht.
Also das höchste, was ich mal hatte war 184.
Als ich mal voll die Brücke hochgerannt bin.
Nachdem ich schon 2-3 Kilometer gelaufen bin.
Aber...
Da war ich auch nicht so richtig kaputt.
Das müsste man halt mal auf irgendeinem Sportplatz testen.
Wo es halt genau gerade geht.
Gucken.
Was das so ist.
Weil...
Das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt zu wissen.
Neue NeoWim Stable Version.
Nice to release NeoWim.
Also sollen wir mal gucken.
Bam.
Vor einer Stunde.
Nee.
Development Pre-Release.
Das war was anderes.
Vor 3 Tagen.
Was sagt die Waage?
Weiß ich nicht.
Soll ich mich mal draufstellen?
Chatkill.
Ihr dürft es euch jetzt aussuchen.
Soll ich schnell...
Es dauert 1-2 Minuten.
Soll ich schnell rüber ins Bad rennen und mich draufstellen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
War da schon eine Weile nicht mehr drauf.
Ich kann rüber rennen ins Bad und gucken.
Soll ich...
Okay, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wieder da.
92,55.
Allerdings mit T-Shirt, Socken und Hose an.
Also wenn man da noch ein bisschen was abzieht,
dann mal so...
Ich sag einfach mal 92.
Ich hab auch schon was gegessen jetzt und was getrunken.
Also das, was ich rausgeschwitzt hab,
hab ich auch wieder aufgefüllt.
Also...
Ich hatte...
Ich hatte letztens...
Letztens bin ich mir wirklich zackig gerannt.
Hab mich danach...
Nackig auf die Waage gestellt.
Da hatte ich hund...
Äh, nicht 100.
Was war das?
191.
91,
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich muss nachgucken.
91,78 oder irgendwie sowas.
91,87?
Ich glaube 91,78.
Was gar nicht so übel ist.
Natürlich, wenn ich wende dich danach.
Wenn du ordentlich Liter trinkst und so,
da wickst du halt schon mal gleich ein bisschen mehr.
Von einem halben Liter.
Du trinkst...
Was hab ich da rausgeschwitzt?
Also, ich find das wirklich super nice,
diese App von Garmin.
Ich mein, ey, keine Ahnung, wie genau das Ganze ist, ja?
Ja, also mir schon.
Wie geht's dir, Brionic?
Klingt ein bisschen wie diese Lego-Dinger.
Also ich find die App mega nice.
Wie genau das ist, sei mal dahingestellt, ja?
Aber die zeigt dir,
die zeigt dir, wie viele Kalorien man verbraucht hat.
Also die sagt, dass ich heute 510 verbraucht habe mit der Runde.
Wobei, die kann das ja auch nur grob sagen.
Wobei, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht mal so weit von der Realität weg,
weil die Uhr hat ein GPS drinne.
Die Uhr weiß, wie schwer ich bin, wie schnell ich bin.
Und erkennt Steigungen und sowas.
Ich glaube, die kann das relativ gut ausrechnen.
Und was ich auch ganz interessant finde, ist,
die weiß halt über die App, die kennst halt auch die Temperatur und sowas.
Die sagt, ich habe 777 Milliliter Schweiß verloren, also Wasser.
Ich finde das immer ganz interessant, was da an Stats drinne stehen.
Du hast einen Fehler gemacht. Ja, machen wir alle.
Das ist normal, du machst permanent Fehler.
Und da gibt's halt diese Redensart so nach dem Motto,
ja, ich weiß nicht, wie's geht. Irgendwie,
wenn man, aus Fehlern muss man lernen und wenn man zweimal macht, ist man blöd und so.
Wobei, das auch nicht stimmt, weil, ganz ehrlich, ganz viele Leute machen das.
Die machen ganz viele Sachen mehr als einmal falsch.
Es dauert manchmal ein bisschen, bis man rausgelernt hat.
Geht nicht nur first try und auch nicht second try.
Manchmal dauert's, keine Ahnung, eleven try.
Zum Beispiel, ganz einfaches Beispiel, dass dieses,
man ist, wenn es total blöd, wenn man Fehler zweimal macht, nicht stimmt, ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr nehmt euch regelmäßig vor,
ich mache jetzt immer, nachdem ich auf dem Klo war, den Klodeckel zu.
Und ich habe vorher nie den Klodeckel zugemacht.
Meint ihr, ihr kriegt das first oder second try hin? Im Leben? Nein.
Im Leben nicht.
Ihr braucht da, ihr braucht da zwei Monate für, bis ihr euch dran gewöhnt habt.
Ich, also, ich spreche da aus Erfahrung, weil normalerweise, ich habe nie den Klodeckel zu,
also, ich rede jetzt, nachdem man fertig ist, dann zumachen.
Warum man zumachen sollte? Ganz einfach.
Weil meine Katze der Meinung ist, sich auf den Klorand zu stellen und aus dem dreckigen Klo zu trinken.
Seitdem mache ich den Klodeckel immer zu.
Und da habe ich bestimmt zwei Monate gebraucht, bis ich mich dran gewöhnt habe, dass ich, nachdem ich auf dem Klo war,
und fertig bin, den Klodeckel wieder zumachen muss.
Aber mittlerweile habe ich mich dran gewöhnt, jetzt geht es automatisch. Das dauert aber ein bisschen.
Meine Freundin ist wegen der Arbeit außerhalb und ich bin in der Zeit, wo sie nicht da war, rückfällig geworden.
Naja, kommt drauf an, wegen was.
Abspülen mit offen...
Ja, Chat, ihr habt wieder super Gedanken, ich sehe es schon.
Chat geht jetzt wieder on point.
So, lasst uns mal, lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Was gibt es denn Neues in der Neowim?
In der letzten Neowim-Version.
Ah, das ist, das ist, das finde ich cool.
Der Codename von dem Editor ist jetzt Bram oder Bram, wahrscheinlich Bram spricht man es aus.
Das ist der originale Wim-Erfinder.
Nicht VI, Wim.
Genau, und der ist, der ist gestorben vor einem Monat oder eineinhalb Monaten.
Help Uganda.
Ja, der hat, also immer wenn Wim geöffnet wurde, ohne Datei,
stand ein Spendenhinweis drinnen für Kinder in Uganda, glaube ich.
Deswegen, Help Uganda.
Dabri.
Was gibt es denn Neues?
Irgendwelche Special-Dinger?
Keine Ahnung.
Windows-Taste und Alt-Taste.
Okay, ging das noch nicht.
Dann würde ich mir zweimal überlegen, ob ich das an die große Glocke hänge, wenn sie wieder da ist.
Das andere ist wahrscheinlich für sie nicht so schlimm.
Aber letztendlich musst du das wissen.
Wir können hier.
Twitch-Chat ist immer so ein Ding.
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen groß?
Leute, ich checke die Hälfte der, der Neowim-Changes nicht.
Aber wenn wir gerade schon, wenn wir gerade schon auf, auf Shadhub sind,
können wir doch bei der Gelegenheit auch grad mal
gucken,
was so trendet.
Das übliche, AI wird übersprungen.
AI, äh AI?
Eine Programmiersprache, wo man nicht mal,
mal examples im readme hat ach das kenne ich das ist doch diese peisen dieses preisen verschnitt
ding das was was quasi heißen sonntags plus extra ist und dann irgendwie nach ziel plus
plus übersetzt oder sowas geld das ist das habe ich doch habe ich doch letztens irgendwie mein
artikel darüber gelesen glaube ich zumindest was ich jetzt persönlich noch ganz spannend finden
würde ist wo ist denn der source code der source code von der programmiersprache hier nicht hier
sind nur die examples wo ist wo ist die wo ist die implementierung das wird mich tatsächlich
noch interessieren source code getting started wo ist der source code dazu change log ist das
ist das nicht open source kann das sein das ist das okay das ist nicht open source na gut dann
habe ich keinen bock mehr
kraft ist zu verwenden habe schon gedacht hier kann man sich den source code mal angucken
möchte mich interessieren in wasser implementiert haben und was da sonst noch so drumherum ist weil
so ich weiß nicht in der aktuellen zeit es gibt eigentlich keinen grund mehr keine open source
entwicklungs technologien mehr zu finden das meiste wichtige ist open source es gibt immer
noch so ein paar kleine nischen dinge zum beispiel wenn man irgendwelche oracle geschichten braucht
irgendwelche srp
geschichten oder was auch immer irgend welche ínges die proprietären sachen anzusprechen aber das
allermeiste ist mittlerweile den source ja von der sprache bis zu vielen language tools bis zu den
meisten der wichtigen libraries eigentlich mehr oder weniger alle wichtige also im prinzip ist
es im prinzip egal ja auch die compiler implementierung interpreter implementierung
implementieren was auch immer runtimes ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger bei den wichtigsten
sachen heute open source egal ob die jahr anguckt ihr könnt es ja auch wieder super unsere nhiara
eigentlich mehr oder weniger bei den wichtigsten sachen heute offen sonst egal ob jetzt die scharfan cook holding
open source ist nämlich auch ein kurzes versuch wenn jetzt keine granden teile applied artist ist es geht's auch so ein Okay das war am Anfang des noche glily making art individualermaßen ist übrigens die letzte skeptical verse 24 und das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger vieler bei den wichtigsten sachen heute open source egal ob
jetzt ist die sharp anguckt da gut bei c sharp gibt es bei den entwicklertools die ein oder
anderen klaus sachen von microsoft noch aber die braucht man nicht unbedingt zumal wenn man
leider verwendet was übrigens auch klaus sache ist brauche ich ja nicht ja war gerade sind sehr
viele am schwenken auf open jdk weiß gar nicht ob noch irgendjemand neue projekte mit java enterprise
anfängt open source sind schon immer open source ruby sogar c und c++ wobei man da halt sagen muss
da gibt es ja keine referenz implementierung in dem sinne wobei bei c weiß ich war c++ gibt es
keine da gibt es ja so ein paar die verbreitet sind aber keine offizielle offizielle standard
implementierung rast eigentlich so mehr oder weniger alles wichtige alles alles wichtige
ist
, eigentlich mittlerweile open source inklusive runtime sprach sprach guides specs tools meistens
auch editor plugins und alles also ich weiß nicht warum ich in eine sprache die komplett
klaus sache verwenden sollte du weißt im endeffekt ja nie was es macht nicht dass es nicht dass man
jetzt dann stand hat man sich immer unterstellen müsste die würden irgendwelche komischen sachen
treiben aber ich finde immer ein bisschen problematisch sachen einzusetzen wo man gar
nicht die
chance hat nachzugucken was macht das geht mir bei windows ja auch immer auf den sack bei windows hast
du keine ahnung ja bei windows guckst du manchmal hier kenne das also mal angenommen ihr macht ihr
task manager auf das jetzt einfach mal hier task manager auf macht task manager auf also
ich nehme es hier prozess explorer war mal da ja vorher schon wieder da waren so und dann sortiert
mir das war so und wenn man hier durch scrollt kenn ihr das manchmal gibt es da ein random zu irgendwelche
neuen Sachen, die aufploppen in den Windows-Dingern.
Und du hast keine Ahnung, was ist das?
Ja, zum Beispiel das hier. Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Unseacab. Was ist es? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Alles klar. Unseacab. Noch nie gesehen.
Ist mir komplett neu, dass es das gibt.
Da tauchen manchmal irgendwelche random Sachen auf.
Was ich übelst kacke finde.
Guck mal. Open Console. Was zum Teufel ist Open Console?
Ah, Microsoft Terminal. Okay, alles klar.
Ja, OBS und so.
Tja, das ist halt richtig dumm.
Das mag ich unter Linux. Da weiß ich, was läuft.
Und wenn ich nicht weiß, was es ist,
oder was als Abhängigkeit installiert wird,
kann ich immer danach suchen.
Gucken, was es ist.
Real Agent Smith. Danke schön für den Sub.
Und Darkseid.
Und Vegan Nico.
Und der Agent Smith. Danke für den Sub, Leute.
Progu.
Kannst du mal darauf reagieren?
Was?
Äh...
What the fuck?
TikTok. Nee.
Aus Prinzip nicht.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist Cringe-Joke.
Gibt es gute Postman-Native?
Die sind leider auch kein Open Source und führen jetzt Accounts wangern.
Wirklich?
Waren die nicht mal Open Source?
Haben die das...
Haben die das irgendwie rückgängig gemacht?
Und...
Und vor allem...
Vor allem...
warum Accounts fangen?
Ne, ist doch Open Source das Ding.
Hier, guck. Ach ne,
oder auch nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ja, es gibt gute Postman
Alternativen, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich bin von Postman auch schon komplett weg
mittlerweile. Ich benutze die Dinger,
ich benutze die Dinger gar nicht. Also, es gibt
es gibt
mittlerweile in
Visual Studio Code selbst
eingebaut sowas.
Ich glaube,
ähm, wie ging das?
Ich glaube, man musste
eine Datei HTTP nennen
und dann konnte Visual Studio Code
mittlerweile sogar selbst sowas.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert. Habe ich letztes Mal
im Tutorial gesehen. Es gibt aber, ich weiß
aus dem Kopf keins, aber es gibt zig
es gibt zig solcher Dinger.
Es gab ja mal eine Zeichnung
Postwoman, weil irgendjemand
gedacht hat, Postman
dann muss es auch, aber das wurde ja umbenannt.
Irgendwas anderes.
Man konnte doch
jetzt, das ist doch neu, ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Man konnte
doch irgendwie eine Datei, keine Ahnung,
pluck, plupp, .http
nennen. War das so?
Ne.
Das konnten die doch jetzt eingebaut,
oder?
Ach, ich weiß nicht mal, wie das geht.
Ich habe da letztes Jahr in einem Tutorial
drüber gesehen.
Man kann jetzt,
man kann jetzt irgendwie diese Get-Request und direkt
Visual Studio Code machen, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also, so scheint es zumindest schon mal nicht zu gehen.
Doch, habe ich letztes Jahr
in einem Tutorial gesehen.
Man kann jetzt, man kann jetzt
HTTP-Dateien oder irgendwie sowas anlegen,
dann direkt reinschreiben, Get, bla bla bla,
irgendwie. Letztes Jahr das Tutorial
drüber geguckt.
Anwendest du ein zusätzliches Virenprogramm unter
Windows? Nö.
Nur Standard Windows Defender.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz hier
die Klimaanlage anmachen, es ist übelst warm schon.
Aber das ist eh nervig.
Pia Champ V2
schon wieder outdated.
Habe ich gesehen, dass es rausgekommen ist, ja.
Aber dürfte relativ easy sein zu upgraden.
Und das neue Theme sieht viel hübscher aus
als das alte Standard-Theme.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich dann auch benutzen.
Aber ich komme eh aktuell nicht wirklich zu,
da was zu machen.
Ich habe auch letztens wieder in die Issues geguckt,
da gibt es sogar wieder neue, ja, ne.
Ne, ne, das war es nicht.
Es gab offiziell, ich habe letztens ein Tutorial geguckt,
das ist jetzt irgendwie offiziell, dass man,
oder war das in Rider?
Vielleicht war es auch in Rider und ich bring's nicht,
es ist Heider, Alter.
Rider.
Ach, das war in Rider standardmäßig mittlerweile drinne.
Dann habe ich, dann habe ich das durcheinandergebracht.
Genau.
Man braucht, man muss eine Datei anlegen,
.http oder .rest.
Und dann kann man direkt da drin
Get-Requests und Post-Requests und so Zeug ausführen,
was ich eigentlich ganz nice finde.
Aber stimmt, das, ich, ich hab's,
dann habe ich durcheinandergebracht im Kopf,
dass ich dachte, es ist in VS Code,
aber nein, es ist anscheinend nur in den JetBrains,
Dingern.
Aber neben das, was,
irgendjemand hat's doch, hat doch gerade Hopscotch vorgeschlagen.
Probier mal das aus.
Das ist, glaube ich,
der Postman-Nachbau,
der ursprünglich mal Postwoman hieß,
den sie dann umbenannt haben in Hopscotch.
Finde ich auch, ich fand den Namen auch bescheuert.
So nach dem Motto,
okay, es gibt nen Postman,
wir machen jetzt aus Prinzip ne Post,
ein Programm, was Postwoman heißt.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Man kann, man kann's auch übertreiben.
Mit, mit aufgeweckt sein.
Aber jeder darf natürlich sein
Open-Source-Programm nennen, wie er will.
Weil,
das ist ja sein Projekt.
Aber Hopscotch, weiß nicht, klingt irgendwie griffiger.
Das weißt du ja heutzutage eh nie.
Manche nehmen das
bitter ernst, so alles.
Ich hab letztens wieder richtig bescheuerte Diskussion
mitgekriegt. Da wurde drüber
diskutiert,
ob, äh, ob man
Baldur's Gate 3 spielen kann,
weil angeblich wäre Baldur's Gate
3, ähm,
ihr kennt ja das Standardzeug,
was da immer geschrieben wird, so nach dem Motto,
äh, nur gemacht, um
irgendwie
besonders Vogue
zu sein und bla, und sonst wie was.
Die, die, Leute, ich sag,
alle beide Seiten, die spinnen komplett.
Also bei Baldur's Gate 3
hab ich noch nie was davon gemerkt.
Klar, du kannst, du kannst irgendwie
als, ja, richtig kek Alu, man.
Du kannst als männlicher,
äh,
Protagonist quasi dann
männliche NPCs romanzen,
wobei das jetzt nun wirklich nicht neu ist.
Ich bilde, ich bilde mir sogar ein,
dass man in
Dragon Age Origin sogar schon,
ja doch, relativ sicher,
äh, wie hieß
der Tank aus Dragon Age Origin,
der blonde, ich hab vergessen, wie heißt,
Companions,
ähm,
Alister,
genau, ja,
den mein ich.
Den mein ich.
Den konnte man, glaub ich, in Dragon Age auch schon romanzen
als, als, äh, male
Charakter. Also so neu ist das nicht.
Das kam 2009 oder so
raus. Ja.
Also,
ist jetzt, ist jetzt nix, nix Neues.
Übrigens auch richtig, richtig nice, das Game.
Falls noch jemand nicht gespielt hat.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
ich finde, Baldur's Gate 3
ist ein ziemlich
gutes,
ziemlich guter Nachfolger
von Dragon Age Origins.
Vom Kamera-Angle her, ein bisschen
von der Graphic her,
passt gut. Es ist halt nicht, Dragon Age ist halt
nur intern turn-based, aber
an sich kannst du es Realtime
mit Pause spielen.
Also richtig, richtig nice ist das Game.
Ja, und da haben sie sich wieder aufgeregt drüber. Ich weiß nicht, was, was
da heutzutage los ist.
Überall wird's schon über jeden Scheißhunder aufgeregt.
Hier sind noch bestimmt genug
Vin, Zac bis Dev, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Der Hälfte des Chats ist
Vin bis Zac
Full Stack
Dev bis
DevOps.
Welche IDE nutzt ihr hauptsächlich
für Kubernetes, Helm, Terraform, Deployments?
Visual Studio Code.
Also ich,
ich mach Kubernetes Manifest
in Visual Studio Code,
Helm-Jammel-Zeug in Visual Studio Code
und Terraform
HCL
TF-Files.
In Visual Studio Code.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, ne?
Terraform
ist eines der meistverbreiteten Produkte
so im Cloud-Umfeld.
Aber generell, der IDE
Support ist richtig Schrott.
Ganz ehrlich, richtig
Schrott.
Ich glaub, das ist sogar
ich glaub, das ist sogar offizielles Terraform
Plugin vom Hersteller. Guck mal hier!
Kein Wunder, das hat absichtlich
absichtlich, also absichtlich
nicht absichtlich, vergiss, verdient
hatte so schlechte, so schlechte
Bewertung.
Das ist richtig Shit!
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie es sein kann, dass bei so einem
verbreiteten Produkt, einem so
beliebten und
viel benutzten Produkt
warum
der Editor in IDE Support
bei Terraform so ultra
scheiße ist. Anders kann man's nicht
sagen. Ich mein,
die Basics funktionieren ja oftmals noch nicht.
Ich würde, ganz ehrlich,
wisst ihr, was das Mindeste ist, was ich erwarten
würde von so einer
Extension? Das ist, dass
es ordentlich die Datei formatieren kann.
Ich erwarte noch nicht mal großartiges
Autocomplete oder sowas.
Ich erwarte, dass wenn es eine
Terraform Extension gibt,
dass du sagst, okay, ich schreib
jetzt hier irgendwas rein, plupp gleich eins,
ich drück speichern, der formatiert
die Datei und dann ist die richtig formatiert.
Nicht mal das funktioniert.
Manchmal formatiert das einfach gar nicht.
Weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der Language Server
abgekackt ist oder das Plugin kacke ist.
Die Intellisense geht
regelmäßig kaputt.
Die geht dann einfach nicht. Dann sagst du
dann, local Punkt
und wunderst dich, warum nix kommt?
Ich, also wirklich, es ist mir
unerklärlich, wie man
von so einem verbreiteten,
beliebten, ja an sich ja auch
guten Produkt eine so beschissene
Entwicklungsplattform bieten kann, wie das
HashiCorp mit diesem VS Code Plugin.
Es ist mir komplett unbegreiflich.
Keine Ahnung. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es
da vielleicht, gibt es da vielleicht
für Jetbrains irgendwas besseres?
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, oder?
Das ist, das ist richtiger, richtiger Schrott.
Das versteh ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, warum das so kacke ist.
Ja und, ja, ganz ehrlich,
die,
das Helm Plugin ist auch kacke.
Da kannst du Autocomplete und sowas
auch komplett vergessen.
Ich glaube, ich glaube das Helm Plugin
macht einen kompletten Abgang,
wenn du
mehr als eine Ressource irgendwie
Profile anlegen willst, dann geht's Autocomplete
nicht richtig. Dann gehen nur noch die Helm
Autocomplete Sachen, aber die Kubernetes
Autocomplete Sachen sind dann kaputt und sowas.
Ganz, ganz furchtbar. Ich versteh's
ehrlich gesagt, ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Man muss ja sagen, das hier und gerade
auch in Kombination dürfte so eines
der meistverwendeten Sachen in der Cloud
sein. Ich weiß nicht, warum die, wie sagt man
so schön, Entwickler Experience so
kottenschlecht ist. Und selbst Kubernetes
Manifest anlegen in Visual
Studio Code ist nicht so dolle.
Aber das geht noch. Aber sobald man
das in Helm anlegen will, ist komplett
unusable.
Ich versteh's nicht. Ich versteh auch nicht, warum da nicht mal
irgendeiner hingeht und
sagen wir mal, wenn er es halt als
Visual Studio Code Plugin nicht
hinbekommt, dann
da irgendwie
einen eigenen Editor für baut
oder sowas. Oder warum JetBrains
sich um die Idee kommt mit der Cloud
Native IDE oder sowas.
Weil das ist wirklich abartig.
Also ich
verwende auch VS Code, aber man kann's nicht richtig
Das ist wirklich schrottig.
Richtig, richtiger Müll.
Am besten ist tatsächlich
immer zweite
Ja, das auch.
Das auch, ja.
Am besten ist echt immer Terminal aufhaben
und alle 10 Sekunden mal
ausführen und gucken, ob alles noch funktioniert.
Also ich hab vor jedem
Commit, was ich mache
was Terraform angeht
hab ich ein
TF-Lint, ein TF-Format davor.
In der CLI
weil man sich nicht drauf verlassen kann, dass das Format
richtig funktioniert
und Terraform ja der Meinung ist, manche
Sachen sind erlaubt und manche nicht.
Das ist eh weirdchampig, ja.
Es ist
extrem weird. Also zum Beispiel
darfst du in Terraform, darfst du sowas hier
machen. Tun wir mal so
als wäre das Terraform, ja.
Also was du machen darfst, ist irgendwie so eine Inline-Funktion
So, zack, zack.
So, also sowas
darfst du machen in Terraform
zum Beispiel. Ja, da kommt dann ein String
raus, wo diese Variable an der Stelle eingesetzt
wird. Was du in Terraform nicht machen
darfst, ist sowas.
Ohne eine Warnung zu bekommen.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt
Warum? Ich hab
keine Ahnung.
Hier sagen sie, oh nein, Empty String Interpolation
soll man nicht benutzen.
Das Problem ist nur,
wenn das hier ein Int ist,
dann könnte man zwar
dann könnte man zwar so schreiben,
aber dann bleibt es ein Int. Das heißt,
ich müsste dann sowas machen.
So, und jetzt
ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht
was besser ist. Also
ich persönlich bin der Meinung, das hier
Chat, was meint ihr?
Was ist syntaktisch
schöner? Wenn das hier
ein Int ist, 0 ist ein Int, ja.
Int 0 gleich 1. Das ist zwar nicht Terraform,
aber ihr wisst. So.
Ich will das hier als
String rauskommen am Ende.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich
finde das hier einfach angenehmer.
Zumal man normalerweise String Interpolation
ja so auch macht. Aber warum ist
das deprecated? Ich verstehe es nicht.
Das ist hässlich
wie die Nacht, Alter. Ich weiß nicht, was sich die Leute da ausgedacht haben.
Ja.
Ich verstehe, ganz ehrlich,
keine Ahnung. Ich hasse Terraform
richtig mittlerweile.
Und hell mag ich auch nicht.
Weil die Go-Template so ein Tagsrichtiger
Abfuck ist. Ich finde Terraform ist übelst
der Rotz. Die anderen Sachen
sind aber auch nicht so viel geiler.
Jetzt kommt ihr noch dabei. Terraform
ist ja noch eigentlich das Beste. Allein schon durch
die Riesenmenge an Module und
Verbreitung, die es gibt.
Ich finde ja vom Ansatz
her Pulumi ganz nice, aber das ist nicht so
verbreitet und bringt ja auch nichts,
wenn man das als einziger verwendet.
Relativ regelmäßig.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt jeden Tag
da dran rumbau.
Value Files editiere ich jeden Tag.
Helm-Charts selbst
relativ unregelmäßig.
Aber kommt doch oft genug vor.
Das letzte Helm-Chart,
was ich gebaut habe, ist eins um
Ich überlege gerade, was war das?
Erigon?
Ist das Ethereum?
Ja.
Ist um eine
Ethereum-Blockchain
Gedöns in Kubernetes
zu deployen. Da braucht man
zwei Sachen. Da braucht man
Oh, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Du brauchst zwei Sachen.
Du brauchst irgendwie den
Transaction-Layer
und den, ach keine Ahnung,
Blockchain-Zeug. Ich frage mich nicht.
Ich mache zwar seit Monaten in so einem Blockchain-Projekt mit,
aber
Blockchain selbst kann ich mir die Hälfte nicht merken.
Ist mir auch vollkommen egal.
Interessiert mich auch gar nicht.
Ja, das war das letzte, was ich gebaut habe,
um Ethereum-Blockchain-Sachen
in Kubernetes deployen zu können.
Ich wollte ja gucken, was auf GitHub trendet.
Pre-Commit-Hook.
Bietet sich an.
Ja.
Ist nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man Leute hat, die in der Lage sind,
Git auf der CLI zu verwenden.
Ja.
Wisst ihr, ein Nachteil von GitHub,
GitLab und solche Sachen ist,
SelfmadeEyes, Dankeschön,
dass die alle keine Git-Hooks mehr unterstützen.
Jemand hat doch geschrieben,
hier haben wir einen
Pre-Commit-Hook drinnen.
Also Pre-Commit ist ja lokal im Git-Repo.
Aber es gibt sowas wie
Pre-Receive bei Git
als Hook. Das war äußerst praktisch.
Da konnte man, wenn jemand in das
zentrale Repo, oder was heißt zentral,
wirklich zentral ist ja bei Git kein Repo,
aber das, worauf man sich geeinigt hat,
dass von dort alle pullen und pushen,
da konnte man früher sowas wie
einen Pre-Receive-Hook reinhauen
und sobald
der Pre-Receive-Hook
irgendeinen Fehler festgestellt hat,
konntest du den kompletten Push ablehnen.
Nicht mehr, weil das alles
asynchron passiert in GitLab und GitHub.
Du kannst keine
Git-Hooks mehr machen. Du kannst natürlich
irgendwelche Jobs automatisch triggern,
aber bringt ja nichts, dann ist es schon gepusht.
Das wird dadurch ein bisschen
aufgeweicht, dass
du auf GitHub einfach sagen kannst,
du musst ein Pull-Request machen, also ist es egal.
Aber trotzdem, ich find's ein bisschen
doof, dass du keine
richtigen...
Ja, Bitbucket kann das, ich weiß, aber nur
mit Java. Da brauchst du irgendeinen
Java-Hook, ist auch für'n Arsch.
Oder du musst aufs File-System gehen.
Etwas blöd,
ja. Ich fänd das
wirklich nice, würde GitLab und GitHub
noch richtig echte
Pre-Receive-Hooks anbieten.
So, ich wollt mir angucken, was trendet.
Da hab ich immer noch nicht gecheckt, was es
eigentlich ist.
Ich hab's mir letztens schon angeguckt,
aber keine Ahnung, was das
sein sollte. Es ist im Prinzip doch
einfach nur ein Dashboard, oder?
Ach nee, das ist irgendeine Linux-Distriktion,
mit vorinstalliertem
Nextcloud und Home Assistant
oder sowas.
Wen juckt's? Bann!
Da gucken wir uns gleich ein Fireship-Video
dazu an.
Incredible Fast JavaScript
Runtime.
Written in SICK, nicht in Rust!
Deswegen ist es auch nicht Blazingly Fast, sondern
Incredibly Fast.
Weil, weil...
Blazingly Fast
dürfen nur Rust-Programme sein.
Was ist das?
Ist das sowas wie Chef?
Nur
für Windows?
Ja,
anscheinend. Kann man auch im
Browser benutzen einfach, oder?
JQ trendet.
Wie kommt denn das auf einmal?
Beste.
React trendet.
Extreme Firmware.
Das ist irgendwas für 3D-Drucker.
Wisst ihr, manchmal fänd ich's echt gut,
wenn die Leute in ihre Readme schreiben würden,
was es eigentlich ist.
Jetzt, jetzt mal ernst...
Leute, ich hab mal ne ernst gemeinte Frage für euch.
Wenn ihr diesen Text hier lesen würdet, ja?
The DOM amongst the Flipper Zero Firmware.
Give your Flipper the power and freedom
it is...
So, würdet ihr daran denken, dass das hier
sich um Firmware für einen 3D-Drucker handelt?
Oder bring ich das
durcheinander? Ist das überhaupt nicht für einen 3D-Drucker?
Siehste?
Kann sogar sein, dass ich verkehrt liege.
Ach nee, der hieß Clipper, oder?
Ach, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Clipper ist die 3D-Drucker-Firmware.
Flipper ist dieses
WLAN-Hacking-Device.
Ah, siehste? Jetzt bin ich
durcheinander gekommen.
Es hat aber auch recht ähnliche Namen.
Hier.
Flipper WiFi. Das ist dieses orange...
Ja, orange...
weiße Ding.
Blazingly fast, written in rust.
Power Toys.
Und Fii.
Eine Library zum Investment
für...
Was?
AI. Geh weg.
So wirklich
spannend find ich jetzt
eigentlich nur das.
Aber solange das nicht Open Source ist, weiß ich nicht,
ob ich es benutzen soll.
Achso, meine Schuhe.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir es überstanden haben.
Es ist immer noch die Hälfte AI.
Und wer weiß.
Das ebbt jetzt ein bisschen ab.
Und sobald, keine Ahnung,
GPT-45 oder sowas um die Ecke kommt...
Gibt's da eigentlich schon Pläne für?
Nee.
Es gibt nur AI-generierte
Seiten, die über AI-Sachen
spekulieren. Auch nice.
Wisst ihr, was die richtige Seuche ist
auf Reddit?
Chat-GPT-Antworten.
Es gibt so viele Chat-GPT-Bots
mittlerweile auf Reddit, die können sie gar nicht
alle bannen.
Man erkennt das aber.
Meistens.
Meistens erkennt man's.
Weil die Antworten so...
so füllig sind.
Wisst ihr, die normale Reddit-Antwort ist
so nach dem Motto, es geht einer auf Reddit
und sagt
ähm
Wenn ich aufs Klo gehe, ist mein Haufen
so schwer, dass der Klo ihn nicht wegspülen kann.
So. Was soll ich tun?
Geht er auf Reddit.
Die normale Reddit-Antwort ist halt irgendwie
so ein Satz, was richtig dumm ist.
Vielleicht zwei Sätze, irgendwie ein bisschen was
hilfreiches. Und sobald dann da eine
Antwort kommt, die irgendwie
zehn Sätze
enthält und
nur vage auf das eigentliche Problem
eingeht, dann weißt du
immer, okay, AI-Antwort.
Ja.
Und merken das
die Anwender, die bei dir ein Ticket
aufmachen? Ich kann mich nicht
mehr dran erinnern. Ich hab letztens was
gegoogelt, als ich Baldur's Gate 3
gespielt hab.
Hab ich irgendwas gegoogelt, was halt überhaupt
nicht obvious in dem Game ist.
Genau.
Ich weiß wieder, was ich gegoogelt hab.
Und zwar, ich
wollte gucken, ob es in Baldur's Gate noch
einen Ring of Protection gibt,
außerhalb von dieser einen Quest.
Weil eigentlich ist
so im D&D Setting Ring of Protection
so der 0815 Ring, den es in jeder Ecke gibt.
Da dachte ich mir, ey, guck doch mal,
ob es irgendwie außerhalb von dieser Quest noch
einen Ring of Protection gibt.
So, und da hab ich gesucht,
hab einen Reddit-Post gefunden,
und irgendwie die zweite Antwort
auf diesem Reddit-Post war
sehr sicher ChatGPT.
Ist überhaupt nicht darauf eingegangen,
sondern nur so diese
Standard-ChatGPT-Geschichte.
So, ja,
als ich Baldur's Gate 3
gespielt habe,
habe ich selbst nach einem Ring of Protection
gesucht, also ich übersetze euch das irgendwie
sinngemäß, habe ich selbst nach einem Ring of Protection
gesucht, leider konnte ich
auch beim Durchspielen
bis zu Akt 3 keinen weiteren
Ring of Protection finden.
Deshalb vermute ich, es befindet
sich in diesem Spiel von den
Programmierern eingebaut, kein weiterer
Ring of Protection. Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
was zum Teufel, keine Sau schreibt so,
das muss eine ChatGPT-Antwort sein.
Und wenn ihr mal genau guckt,
ganz viele Reddit-Posts
sind einfach ChatGPT, und ich verstehe
den Sinn davon nicht.
Was hat man davon, einen Reddit-Bot
mit ChatGPT laufen
zu lassen? Denn, man,
also, wenn die ja wenigstens
spammen würden, so nach dem Motto,
die Antwort findest du hier, und dann kommst du auf einer
virenverseuchten Seite raus, oder auf irgendeiner
bescheuerten
Cash-Crab-Seite von irgendwas,
oder einfach nur Werbe, da würde ich's ja noch
verstehen, aber einfach nur
Textantworten zu generieren, da hat ja
niemand was von, außer dass irgendjemand diesen Bot
laufen lassen muss.
Also, ich verstehe den Sinn wirklich
nicht. Also, sowohl für die Leute, die
die Antwort bekommen von einem ChatGPT-Bot
auf Reddit, als auch für die Leute,
die...
Es gibt Leute, die kaufen Reddit...
Du meinst, die farmen da irgendwie Karma,
und wenn sie dann... Aber damit kriegst du nicht
mal Karma großartig, das dauert ewig.
Vielleicht macht's die Menge.
Die machen einfach 800
Accounts, und spammen
dann rum, und irgendwann haben sie dann nach einem Jahr mal
einen Account mit ein bisschen Karma...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo man Reddit-Karma-Punkte
sieht, ehrlich gesagt.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken auf Reddit. Ich geh mal kurz auf Reddit.
Äh...
Okay.
My Profile?
Nice, ich hab einen Karma-Punkt.
Pog!
Extremely nice!
Aber ich schreibe ja
auf Reddit nicht. Ich lese ja nur
auf Reddit. Ich hab einen Reddit-Post
geschrieben bisher, all den Jahren.
Und...
Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich
einen Reddit-Post finde, hier, Reddit.
Ja, hier! Das... Das meine ich!
Das ist doch ne Chat... Leute, seriously!
Das ist doch ne Chat-GPT-Antwort hier, passt mal auf.
Also, der Typ will wissen, äh...
Gibt es noch weitere Ring of Protections
in Baldur's Gate 3, außer von dieser einen Quest?
So, lest euch diese Antwort mal durch.
Das ist doch... Das ist doch Chat-GPT,
oder?
All I can say for certain is that the Ring is so rare, it's not even
on the wiki for Baldur's Gate 3.
My multiplayer group acquired it, blablabla,
I've been able to confirm where it came from till now.
That being said, the only one is
like... Das ist doch ne Chat-GPT-Antwort!
Das kann mir doch keiner sagen, das so auf Reddit
antwortet.
Er hat auch nicht umsonst minus 14
Dinger. Das ist so ne typische
random, sinnlos
Chat-GPT-Antwort.
That being said, it may
be only one of its likeness
in the whole game, given no one
seems to have a clue... Das ist so typisch...
Das ist ein typischer Chat-GPT-Satz.
Niemand
schreibt so. Niemand schreibt
so. Schon gar nicht auf Reddit.
Okay, der will seine...
Der will seine
Webseite verkaufen.
Das verstehe ich auch, warum das ein Bot ist.
Der will seine Webseite verkaufen.
Also nicht seine Webseite... Der will
Zeug über seine Webseite... Leute auf die Webseite locken.
Ah, verstehe.
Nice, du.
Niemand schreibt so auf Reddit, Alter. Das ist ein Bot.
Also Leute, die auf TikTok sind,
die schreiben nicht so.
Ich kann euch nicht aus eigener Erfahrung sagen,
wie man schreibt, nachdem man auf TikTok war.
Auf TikTok.
Aber...
Nicht so.
Ich würde eher sagen, dass ein TikTok-Zuschauer
sowas macht, so. Der schreibt
dann irgendwie, äh, Hals, Maul,
du K... äh, und dann ist er abgelenkt
und schreibt den Post nie
fertig.
So stelle ich mir einen TikTok-Zuschauer vor.
Der fängt den Post an mit irgendeiner Beleidigung,
so, Hals, Maul, du Kackspast,
oder sowas. Mit einem Satz
ist er abgelenkt und kehrt nie wieder
zu dem Post zurück und postet ihn gar nicht.
So stelle ich mir den 0815 TikTok-
User vor.
Und was haben wir denn hier eigentlich?
DB?
Achso, das war das CCC...
CCC-Talk, dass der...
dass der Bahnnavigator
spyt. Das wollen wir auch noch
irgendwann mal schauen.
Ja, auf Twitch gibt's
auch Bots. Und wisst ihr, was es schon
ewig gibt? Diese Twitter-Bots.
Diese Twitter-Bots, wo irgendwelche
Weiber halbnackig
drauf sind in Profilbild.
Und wenn du dann drüber
haferst über dem Bild, steht dann im Profil
in diesem Mini-Profil-Vorschau
I want sex
free.
Follow my profile.
So. Und...
Die liken dann irgendwelche
irgendwelche Posts von vor drei
Jahren oder so, dass sie in der Timeline
aufploppen. Dann weißt du halt sofort, okay,
I scam. Bann.
Block. Tschüss.
Das bekommst du auf Twitter.
Bekommst du das laufend?
Solche sexy
girls Spambots.
Ja, BX. Es ist ja kein...
XXX-Bots auf X.
Schon TinyGov für Arduino ausprobiert. Nee.
Geht das auf dem ESP32?
Kein I2C,
dann kann ich's nicht richtig...
Kein WiFi! Ja, okay, dann...
Dann ist es ja unsinnig. Das bringt mir ja nix.
No POS.
Okay.
Check it.
Ich bin jetzt in Baldur's Gate in Act 3.
Hab schon über 100 Stunden
in dem Game. Ich mach aber auch jede Quest,
die ich finden kann.
Ich glaube, ich brauch nochmal 50 Stunden
oder so, je nachdem wie lang Act 3 ist.
Bis ich dann durch bin. Wobei,
was man so hört, ist ja, Act 3
ist wohl noch ziemlich
verbuggt an vielen Stellen und auch
im Vergleich zu den zwei
Acten davor etwas
Content und
Options ärmer.
Aber Larian hat ja wohl schon gesagt, sie wollen
jetzt nach dem Riesenerfolg da weiter dran arbeiten.
Also sprich, wahrscheinlich ist es dann
so wie bei Divinity Original Sin
1 und 2, dass es dann irgendwie
nach einem Jahr so eine...
Wie hieß das?
Wie hieß das? So Special Edition oder so gibt.
Da gab's auch so eine...
Definitive Edition.
Ja, aber die wollen tatsächlich ja auch
noch mehr Content und Story Branches und so
einbauen. Die machen eine Definitive
Edition. Geh ich ganz stark von
aus. Ja,
ganz ehrlich, Original Sin 2 hatte auch
das Ding, dass der letzte Act nicht so geil...
Auch Dings, auch Original Sin 1
hatte das, dass der letzte
Act nicht so geil war.
Ist doch nice. Wie machst du das?
Du hast dann irgendwie
von dem Hersteller so einen
Gerät, was das machen kann, mit einem
Relay und das löst du dann mit einem Shelly aus
oder wie? Also so ähnlich
umgedreht hab ich das bei mir auch.
Ich hab
von...
Ich hab ganz vergessen
von wo sind...
Keine Ahnung von was meine Rauchmelder sind.
Irgendwie hat der so ein rotes
Logo.
Gibt's den da für...
Was gibt's denn da für Hersteller?
Ich hab...
Ergibt das Sinn, dass ich zuerst
Divinity 2 und dann Divinity 1 docke?
Du musst auf jeden Fall Divinity Original Sin
spielen, weil Divinity gibt es auch
als Game. Aber du meinst wahrscheinlich
Original Sin.
Die Games haben nicht so viel miteinander
zu tun. Ich würde tatsächlich
eins zuerst spielen und dann
zwei, weil
vom Gameplay her und insgesamt ist
Divinity 2 viel viel
ausgereifter.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, du hast wenig
Bock das Einser zu spielen noch.
Wenn du das Zweier
gespielt hast. Ich fand das Einser
auch extrem gut für die Zeit.
Aber...
Ich weiß nicht, ob
ich das Einser noch mal Bock hätte nach dem Zweier.
Ich weiß nicht...
Ich weiß nicht wo meine Hersteller...
Wir haben uns das ja irgendwann mal im Stream
sogar angeguckt.
Ich hab so ein Gerät
vom Rauchmelderhersteller.
Das schaltet
einen Relay, also das musst du pairen mit den
Feuermeldern.
Ich hab die Feuermelder auch
miteinander verbunden, dass wenn der eine unten
in der Küche auslöst, dann
geht auch meiner oben an.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, ob ich das wirklich so lassen
soll. Ich hab das jetzt seit ein paar Jahren. Ich weiß nicht, ob es
eine gute Idee ist, weil man hört es ja auch
so. Und wenn die alle angehen, dann weißt
du ja gar nicht, wo es genau herkommt.
Man sieht es, der blinkt glaube ich sogar.
Aber trotzdem...
Zumindest, ich hab da so ein Gerät gepairt
vom Hersteller.
Und das habe ich
gepairt
mit den Rauchmeldern
und dann löst das so
einen Relay aus, wenn es Rauchmelder
gibt.
Also wenn es Rauch gemeldet wird. Und das bekomme
ich dann in Home Assistant mit.
Und schickt mir eine Push-Notification aufs Handy.
Stimmt, den Stream
hast du gesehen. Ja, wenn du den Stream gesehen hast,
dann können wir doch mal hier Rauchmelder
suchen.
Habe ich den Stream gelöscht, Leute, weil man den...
...
Das ist der Stream, wo ich den halben Stream
kacken musste, weil ich Dünnschiss hatte,
gell? Den habe ich gelöscht. Ich wollte keinen...
Keinen...
Ich sitze auf dem Clostream und bin die Hälfte des Streams
nicht da machen.
Nochmal. Warte, ich setz mich nochmal...
Ja, das ist...
Das ist dieses Teil hier. Genau.
Hier.
Das löst dann aus und...
Ja.
Stream habe ich anscheinend gelöscht.
Ich würde dir die gleichen
Rauchmelder empfehlen, die ich auch habe.
Ich weiß leider, ELV heißen die.
ELV, Rauch. Jetzt sind mir gerade wieder eingefällten Rauchmelder.
Ja, also ich habe
von denen
eine Kombination
aus, ähm...
Wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie der Mist heißt, Alter.
Das hier... Ne, hieß nicht...
Hier ist das ELV.
Ne, warte mal, warte mal.
Das sind die nicht, glaube ich.
Die sehen anders aus.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass ich vergessen habe, wie meine Rauch...
Okay.
10 Jahres
Rauchmelder.
So viele Hersteller gibt es doch davon wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ach du Scheiße.
Es gibt 30 Milliarden.
Okay, ich muss in die App
gucken vom Handy. Da habe ich das drinnen.
Ich will jetzt wissen, wie meine Rauchmelder heißen.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Amazon. Rauchmelder.
Ei
heißen die. Ei.
Ei.
Jawoll.
Diesen Krempel.
So, die habe ich am Start.
So, und dazu habe ich
in Kombination
RF klingt
gut. Ich weiß
gar nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen IW
und IRF ist.
So, und
dafür braucht man
Ich gucke nochmal bei Amazon, da kann ich das nämlich
genau sagen.
RF. Ja.
So, und da braucht man noch
ein I413.
Lohnt sich
da viel, keine Ahnung. Genau.
Guck mal, wie glücklich der ist, nur weil
er einen Rauchmelder hat.
Genau, da gibt es dieses Ding hier zu kaufen.
Das pairst du ganz normal wie
ein weiterer Rauchmelder.
Und sie haben natürlich wieder
mal kein gescheites
ein gescheites
Bild.
Ein Anschaltplan.
Ja, genau. So sieht das aus.
Das Ding pairst du mit
einem der Rauchmelder.
Zum Beispiel mit
dem da.
Das ist ein Rauchmelder,
da kriegst du so ein Funkmodul dabei,
was angeblich 10 Jahre hält.
Na ja, mal gucken. Bin mal gespannt.
Weiß ich nicht, wie lange das bis jetzt hält.
So, und
die pairst du miteinander
und pairst die mit
dem,
mit diesem Koppelmodul.
Und wie ich das gemacht habe ist,
kannst, also das, das
genau, hier musst du Netzteil
ganz normales 12 Volt
DC Netzteil anschließen.
Kannst du so irgendwie für 5 Euro
bei Amazon kaufen. Netzteil
anschließen. Braucht man nicht.
Braucht man nicht.
Das braucht man nur, wenn man es manuell
auslösen möchte. Zum Alarm
testen oder sowas.
Was wichtig ist, du willst
Störung und
Feueralarm anklemmen.
Also hier,
ähm,
anklemmen an beispielsweise
ein Shelly oder einen ESP32
oder was auch immer.
Irgendwo, wo du Kontakte
erkennen kannst.
Und
ja, so habe ich das aktuell.
Also ich habe, ich habe hier in das Gehäuse
habe ich ein ESP32 eingebaut.
Hier seht ihr ja das Case.
ESP32 eingebaut.
Ich habe Feueralarm angeschlossen und
die Störung angeschlossen.
Der ESP32 hängt im WLAN.
Und wenn der Rauchmelder
auslöst, die sind ja gekoppelt mit dem Ding.
Dann schaltet das, äh,
schaltet das Relay hier.
Und das bekommt der ESP32 mit.
Und dann bekommt es mein Home Assistant mit.
Und wenn es mein Home Assistant mitbekommt,
dann bekomme ich eine Push
Notification, dass es Feueralarm
gab. Und die haben aber anscheinend auch
was Neues sehe ich hier gerade.
Ja, mein I56
IW.
Da muss ich mal gucken, ob was, was an dem,
was an dem vielleicht
besser ist.
Weil die Dinger
kannst du wegschmeißen. Also das nicht, aber die Dinger
kannst du halt wegschmeißen, wenn die Batterie alle ist nach 10 Jahren.
Was nicht so wild ist.
Alle 10 Jahre mal ein paar neue.
Irgendwie 4 neue kaufen, ist ja nicht das Ding.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Guck mal hier, 631 hatte ich da.
Also da musst du halt ein bisschen basteln.
Die Dinger funktionieren komplett bastelfrei.
Wenn du selbst die Sachen abgreifen
willst, musst du halt dieses Koppelmodul holen.
Und entweder halt das offizielle von denen
Tool auslesen,
Smartphone Ding anschließen oder halt
selbst bauen mit dem ESP32.
Oh, gibt es eine neue Season?
Die nächste Generation
der, also die über,
die übertreiben es ja auch schon ein bisschen, oder?
Das Trauerspiel
ist vorbei.
Ist endlich richtig auf Kurs.
GameStar, was ist mit euch los,
Alter?
Jasper, danke für den Sub.
Oder, Max, gibt es da eine neue Season?
Oder warum willst du spielen?
Ich würde ja auf einen CO, ja, ähm,
haben die glaube ich nicht.
Oder hat der auch CO2
drinne?
Was kann der denn alles?
Ne, der kann nur Rauch.
Ja,
aber ich habe keinen Melder.
Bringt ja nichts, wenn die Box einen Ausgang hat.
Okay.
Nice, so.
Lass uns doch mal schauen, was können wir uns denn angucken?
Fahrrad geklaut!
Ja, perfekt, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Fahrrad geklaut.
Finde ich es mit einem AirTag?
Nun ja.
AirTags sind nicht so sonderlich geil, um solche
Sachen nachzuverfolgen, aber
AirTags sind sicherlich besser als nichts.
Das Problem bei AirTags ist halt,
die können von alleine nicht funken, weit genug,
so dass du sie findest, da muss halt
zufälligerweise einer mit dem iPhone in der Nähe sein.
An Flughäfen
und sonst wo kommt es dann auch relativ häufig vor,
aber, ja,
muss nicht unbedingt.
Also, ich glaube, man
findet es damit, aber nicht wirklich
Realtime und auch jetzt nicht sonderlich
gut,
mit Pech gar nicht. Ich glaube, da gibt es
bessere Sachen, um sein Fahrrad zu tracken.
Aber sicherlich besser als nichts.
Ja.
Ich glaube, es ist brauchbar.
Aber das war es dann auch.
Übrigens, eine Sache muss ich
gerade nochmal sagen, weil ich gerade von Baldur's Gate 3 hatte,
ich bin jetzt ja quasi so
erste Hälfte
vom dritten Akt.
Also, eine Sache passt nicht.
Das finde ich passt, aber das ist jetzt kein Problem
wirklich von Baldur's Gate.
Das ist so ein Problem von
generell von vielen RPGs.
Und zwar,
die Companions an sich, muss man
sagen, ist sehr viel Mühe
reingeflossen in Baldur's Gate 3.
Ich mag alle eigentlich, außer
Astarion mit dem
Spiel hier nicht. Der steht einfach nur bei mir
im Lager rum und der juckt mich nicht. Aber
alle anderen
mit denen wird
zumindest regelmäßig gesprochen.
Ich hatte auch
insgesamt schon
fünf in der Party.
Von acht oder so was es gibt.
Also passt.
Aber, was halt gar nicht
oder bei den meisten nicht passt, aber was viele
RPGs nicht hinbekommen,
ist eine, sagen wir mal,
passende
Background
also eine passende
History von
den Companions. Weil, ich versuche
euch mal zu erklären, was ich meine. Das ist keine Spoiler.
Das erfährt man alles innerhalb
der ersten paar Stunden in Akt 1.
Und zwar, nur mal so als
Beispiel. Nehmen wir mal Kalec.
Die war
quasi, wenn man jetzt
D&D-Lore nicht so kennt, die war quasi
in der Hölle und hat dort
für eine quasi Göttin
gekämpft.
In verschiedenen
Schlachten.
Und war dort richtig berühmt und bekannt
als eine der besten
ja
Teufel,
Demon Slayer überhaupt.
Und dann fragt man sich so
Die ist Level 1!
Wie soll
das funktionieren?
Niemand mit Level 1
geht dahin
und metzelt alles weg.
Es ergibt keinen Sinn,
dass die Level 1 ist mit dem Background.
So.
Lea Selle ist ähnlich.
So eines der krassesten
Kriegerinnen, die die
zu bieten haben und
irgendwie Nachfahre
von irgendeiner Königin und sonst was.
Aber, Level 1!
Kriegt nichts auf die Reihe.
Shadowheart
Shadowheart ist ein
ähnlicher Background.
Übelst lang trainiert als Shark Cleric.
Super
advanced in diesem Cleric
Orden und auf geheime
Missionen geschickt und alles.
Level 1!
Bei Shadowheart ergibt das noch irgendwie Sinn.
Weil ja standardmäßig Gedächtnisverlust
und alles. Aber dieses Problem
haben viele RPGs in den
Companion Backstories.
Die müssen aus Gameplay Gründen Level 1 sein.
Aber von der
Geschichte her passt das überhaupt
nicht, dass die Level 1 sind.
Versteht man was ich meine?
Also ich finde die einzigen zwei, wo das wirklich gut
passt ist Gale.
Gale ist zwar
backgroundgeschichtentechnisch
übelst krasser
Wizard, aber
durch sein Missgeschick, nennen wir es mal
so, hat er ja
so ein bisschen seine Macht verloren.
Zumindest kann man das reininterpretieren.
Bei dem ergibt das Sinn, dass der wieder Level 1 ist.
Und bei Will
bei Will ergibt es eigentlich auf den ersten
Blick gar keinen Sinn, weil
Will ja übelst bekannter quasi
ähm, ja nicht
Söldner, aber Held quasi
ist an der Schwertküste,
den alle kennen und sowas.
Aber bei Will macht es insofern
doch Sinn, weil er da viel Einbildung
dabei ist. Weil eigentlich kennt ja
Will niemand.
Der tut immer so, als ist er der übelst
krasse Held und jeder kennt ihn, aber eigentlich kennt
ihn keiner. Und da
ergibt es auch irgendwie Sinn von der
Background Story, dass der Level 1 ist.
Aber bei
Hellsin ergibt es auch keinen Sinn,
dass der Level 1 ist.
Übelst krasser
Erz-Druide-Mega-Mega-
gut-bekannte Level
1.
Ja, ich verstehe,
warum man es aus Gameplay-Gründen
macht,
aber Background-Story-Technisch
passt es einfach nicht.
Bei Astarion keine Ahnung
mit dem Spiel hier nicht.
Das ist richtig. In Baldur's Gate 2 hat es
deutlich besser hingehauen,
weil man da mit Level
8 oder so
anfängt.
Um die Level 8 fängt man da, 7 oder 8.
Fängt man da mit an.
Hat? Nee.
Vielleicht auch, wenn man seinen Char importiert.
Nee, nee, nee. Du startest
nicht mit Level 5. Du startest relativ sicher
in Baldur's Gate mit Level 7 oder 8.
Baldur's Gate 2
Starting Level
Ja, das kommt da damals auch noch ein bisschen
auf die Klasse an.
Ähm, ja.
New Game starts character at level 8.
Correct. Ja, 7 oder 8.
Ja, es
kommt ein bisschen auf die Klasse an.
Ja, es war in den alten Games, war es noch je nach Klasse
ein bisschen unterschiedlich, wann man wie Level
ab hatte.
Gibt es Leute in 2022, die kein iPhone
haben? Ja, der überwiegende Teil der Menschheit
hat kein iPhone. Ich glaube, es haben nur
25% aller Smartphone-Besitzer
ein iPhone. Der Rest hat irgendwas anderes. Hauptsächlich
Android.
iPhone vs. Android. Verbreitung
gucken wir mal. Guck mal.
Guck dir mal hier.
iOS
ist ziemlich angezogen
die letzten Jahre über.
Guck mal hier.
Sind nur noch 70, 30.
Ziemlich, ziemlich gut eigentlich.
Aber ist auch irgendwie verständlich.
Ich hab ja Android auf
Tablets und
gefühlt sieht das jede zweite
Android-Version komplett anders
aus und hat sich
180 Grad gewartet.
Weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so krass ist
wie früher.
Ich glaube, ich hab kein Gerät mit top aktueller
Android-Version.
Nutzt du Temux? Ja, mach ich.
Aber das schreibt man ohne E.
Oder ist das was, was ich nicht kenne?
Ja, sind sie auch.
Deswegen hab ich auch nur
Low-Budget-Geräte,
die ich nicht täglich verwende, sondern
beispielsweise als
Dashboard an der Wand
hängen hab. Ja, verwende ich.
Allerdings immer weniger, weil
mein Terminal mittlerweile solche
Splitting-Sachen
und sowas eingebaut hat.
Wir können theoretisch nachher eine Runde
Baldur's Gate 3 weiterspielen, ja.
Aber ich bin halt mittlerweile schon Akt 3.
Das sagen viele iOS-Besitzer
auch.
Also, wo ich's erlebt hab, ist
auf dem allerersten iPhone SE
hatte ich an meiner Mutter eins gekauft
damals und das war wirklich abfuck
langsam.
Ey, keine Zeit für Fiat Champ. Ich hab auch keinen Bock
gerade. Bin zu
zu, äh,
ja,
Paul.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
Fahrradverfolgung mit AirTags.
Alle Tickets closen,
Projekt archivieren, easy.
Also, Fahrrad geklaut, find ich es mit AirTags.
Let's go.
Das werde ich mir von meinem 3003-Kollegen
Lukas klauen lassen.
Er sagt mir nicht, wo er es versteckt.
Guck mal hier, das ist mein Fahrrad.
Das werde ich mir von meinem 3003-Kollegen
Das Video ist kacke, wenn Chainlord das sagt.
Er sagt mir nicht, wo er es versteckt,
aber ich werde trotzdem versuchen,
das wieder zu finden, weil ich an das Rad
nämlich ein Apple AirTag, ein Billig-AirTag
von Aldi, ein Samsung SmartTag
und ein Teil draufgeklebt habe.
Am besten wäre halt irgendein GPS-Tracker.
Mit Batterie,
das sich automatisch auflädt.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen zu auffällig ist.
Das merkt wahrscheinlich jeder.
Also GPS-Tracker heißt ja,
du kannst ja über GPS niemand tracken.
Das heißt, es ist ein GPS-Empfänger
und irgendwie
eine
IoT-SIM-Karte oder sowas
mit drin zum Senden.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich immer richtig cringe
in irgendwelchen Filmen finde.
So nach dem Motto, ein GPS-Tracker.
Wir tracken ihn über GPS.
Nein, ihr trackt niemand über GPS.
GPS is read only.
Das sind
solche Bluetooth-Findehelfer,
die man mit dem Smartphone anpingen kann
und die dann piepsen.
Und dann kann man zum Beispiel das Schlüsselbund finden,
das sich hinter dem Sofa versteckt hat.
All diese Findehelfer lassen sich aber nicht nur...
Ich habe das letztens tatsächlich benutzt.
Sowas ähnliches.
Und zwar, ich habe mein Handy nicht gefunden.
Und da habe ich an meiner Uhr,
die ja per Bluetooth gepaert ist
mit dem Handy,
an meiner Uhr kann man auswählen
Handy vergessen
und dann macht das Handy Geräusche.
Ich habe ausgewählt Handy vergessen.
Ich habe es erst nicht gehört.
Wie ist das?
Und irgendwann habe ich es gefunden.
Das lag im Wohnzimmer
zwischen
also zwischen dem Sofa
und einem Polster.
Das ist da reingerutscht.
Und zwar, mir ist auch gedämmert.
Warum?
Ich bin vormittags eine Runde gerannt.
Dann bin ich hoch ins Wohnzimmer,
habe das Handy neben mich aufs Sofa gelegt
und habe ein paar Dehnübungen durchgeführt.
Und anscheinend
hat das Handy dann halt in die Sofaritze gerutscht.
Aber es hat funktioniert.
Also es ist sehr praktisch gewesen
mit der Uhr das zu triggern.
Ich hätte übrigens genauso gut
an ein zweites Gerät gehen können
und sagen wie find my iPhone.
Dehnübungen nicht auf dem Sofa,
vorm Sofa.
Wenn man selbst in der Nähe ist,
also wenn das eigene Smartphone
Verbindung über Bluetooth
oder Ultra Wideband aufnehmen kann,
sondern die unterstützen auch alle
das bedeutet, wenn ich meinen Schlüsselbund
an dem so ein Findetag hängt
ausversehen in einen Straßenmülleimer werfe,
dann sendet dieses Tag permanent
ein Signal aus.
Wie so ein Leuchtfeuer vom Leuchtturm.
Und jedes iPhone zum Beispiel,
was vorbeikommt, nimmt das auf
und leitet das weiter dann.
Das ist ja auch sehr sinnvoll,
das so zu machen.
So ein bisschen Schwarmintelligenz.
Eben als Funksignal.
Anrufen ist keine Option.
Doch, das wird auch funktionieren.
Wenn Smartphones,
die an dem Mülleimer vorbeilaufen,
können dieses Signal
Ja, oder ich würde wirklich
meine Mutter anrufen und fragen,
kannst du mich mal anrufen?
Das geht natürlich auch,
wenn ich die Nummer gerade nicht weiß.
Und die senden dann die Position
an den Server.
Ja, und dann kann ich auf meinem Smartphone sehen,
oh mein Schlüsselbund ist da und da im Mülleimer.
Dass eure Smartphones permanent
als Findehelfer mitarbeiten,
das kriegt ihr gar nicht mit.
Ich wollte jedenfalls wissen,
funktionieren diese Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke
wirklich?
Kann ich damit mein Fahrrad auch an einem Ort wiederfinden,
an dem nicht unbedingt super viele Leute
vorbeilaufen?
Die Antworten darauf seht ihr in diesem Video
und auch die Antwort auf die Frage,
warum ich nicht einfach einen GPS-Tracker verwende,
der die Position direkt ins Internet schickt.
Bleibt dran.
Ja gut, das Problem bei GPS-Trackern ist halt,
die sind deutlich größer als so ein Tag.
Insgesamt so.
Man braucht halt irgendwas zum Senden.
Und wahrscheinlich auch akkumäßig
hält es da nicht so lang.
Wobei ich da gar nicht so sicher bin.
Je nachdem, wie oft man das senden lässt,
geht das wahrscheinlich auch voll klar.
Ich hatte mir das mal angeguckt.
Ein
ESP32
mit einem GPS-Modul.
Und das ging eigentlich.
Ich hab mir das mal ausgerechnet.
Wenn man das nur irgendwie
zweimal täglich einschalten lässt,
zum Senden,
das ist natürlich nichts für Live-Tracken,
dann
hielte das glaube ich mit so einer
1200mAh
Batterie
Akku
glaube ich 2 Jahre, 2-3 Jahre oder so.
Das war ganz gut.
Habe ich aber nie umgesetzt.
Ich hab nur mal überlegt,
was man machen könnte.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Homepilot.
Guck mal, das sind alles Homepilot-Smartphone-Geräte.
Ein smarter Gurtwickler für eure Rollläden.
Hat der gerade gesagt Smartphone?
Smart Home, oder?
Das sind alles Homepilot-Smartphone-Geräte.
Ein smarter Gurtwickler für eure Rollläden.
Ich finde immer noch geil, dass es auf Deutsch
einfach Gurtwickler heißt, dieses Ding.
Haben wir dafür keinen besseren Namen
als Gurtwickler?
Ich finde das Wort so kacke.
Ich habe ja auch
einen automatischen Gurtwickler,
den habe ich
aber nie eingebaut.
Ich habe mir
die ganze Hardware dafür gekauft,
um das evaluieren
zu können,
aber ich habe mich
nie dazu durchringen können,
das wirklich zu benutzen.
... oder hier
smarte Heizkörperthermostate
und hier ein smarter Fensterkontakt.
Da seht ihr dann auch, wenn ihr gerade im Urlaub seid,
ob jemand euer Fenster geöffnet hat.
Die Homepilot-Geräte sind 100%
do-it-yourself. Ihr könnt das einfach
selbst einbauen und müsst keine Handwerkerfirma
beauftragen. Die Basis für das
Homepilot-Smartphone...
Do-it-yourself heißt für mich auch, das hat ein offenes Protokoll,
aber das sieht dann nicht so aus.
... ein komplett eigenständiges Funksystem,
das seit über 10 Jahren in Deutschland entwickelt wird.
Was sonst?
Eigenständig ist natürlich kein Zigbee, Z-Wave
oder irgendwas Meta-kompatibles.
Obviously.
Weil das wäre ja auch zu einfach
zu integrieren mit anderen Sachen.
Geräteinfos und Daten sind lokal
auf dem Homepilot-Gateway gespeichert.
Man kann das ganze Smart Home
also jederzeit auch ganz ohne
Internetverbindung bedienen. Und wenn man will,
lassen sich auch unkompliziert Geräte von
Drittanbietern einbauen.
Kameras von Bosch, Abus
oder Axis und so weiter.
Schaut doch mal selbst auf
homepilot-smarthome.de
Das machen wir jetzt auch.
Homepilot
Smart Home
Let's go.
Super glückliche Familie.
Wisst ihr, was das witzige an dem Bild ist?
Ich sehe nicht
ein einziges Smart Home Gerät
auf dem Bild.
Die sind anscheinend ja auch ohne Smart Home glücklich.
Und die haben bestimmt so eine richtige Flashbang-Webseite.
Oh, ein Auge.
Ähm.
Lösung.
Produkte.
Elektrische Gurtwickler.
Wenn der Scheiß ja nicht so teuer wäre.
Rollotron.
Hahaha.
Wetten, das funktioniert nicht?
Ach, die sind das.
Hieß das von denen nicht früher
Hieß das früher nicht
Duo Fern von denen?
Das haben die einfach umbenannt.
Das hieß früher anders.
Keckel.
Guck mal, es gibt eine Home Assistant Integration,
die kaum jemand verwendet.
Ja.
Systematik braucht mittlerweile
wieder
Das ist nicht.
Das geht nicht einfach über Zigbee.
Das ist irgend so ein eigenes.
Irgend so ein eigenes System.
Ja, dann habe ich da echt keinen Bock drauf.
Weiter gucken.
Vier Stunden geschlafen.
Ja, verstehe ich. Vier Stunden ist echt wenig.
Legt schon nochmal hin.
Kannst auch pennen bis 12 oder so.
Werbung Ende.
So, ich habe mir vier Findetags besorgt.
Ein Original Apple AirTag.
Ein Billig AirTag von Aldi namens
Maginon SmartTag.
Ein Samsung SmartTag.
Warum nicht Medion?
Hieß das Aldi-Zeug früher nicht immer Medion?
Ein Teil made.
Das Apple AirTag und Maginon SmartTag benutzen Apples
Wo-ist-Netzwerk.
Das geht also nur mit Apple-Mobilgeräten.
Der Unterschied zwischen Original und Billig-Version
ist nur das im Maginon-Tag fehlende Ultra-Wideband.
Damit kann man direkt auf dem
Ja, und, und, und das iPhones Maginon
wahrscheinlich nicht weiterleiten, oder?
Smartphone-Display sehen,
wenn man mit dem AirTag entfernt ist.
So wichtig ist das aber nicht,
weil man kann die Geräte halt auch einfach
per App piepsen lassen und sie dann so finden.
Der Vorteil vom Billig-AirTag,
ja, da ist ein Loch drin.
Man kann sich das also einfach so ohne Zusatz-Hardware
ans Schlüsselbund hängen.
Bei Apple braucht man noch einen zusätzlichen Schlüsselanhänger,
der Original von Apple...
Übrigens, eigentlich ist es komplett unsinnig,
weil man kann Leute, die einen tracken,
von denen man getrackt werden möchte,
kann man einfach bei iOS,
beziehungsweise wenn beide ein iPhone haben,
dann fangen die Leute an zu fügen.
Sein Handy hat man eh dabei.
Dann tauchen die Leute auf in dieser
Find-My-Contacts-Find-My-Devices-Liste.
...kostet als das AirTag selbst.
Apple verkauft auch AirTag
Schlüsselanhänger von Hermes
für 490 Euro.
What the?!
Was?!
Ich dachte, das heißt Hermes.
Warum zu...
Alter!
Sind die noch ganz bei Trost, oder was?
Das ist ein Stück Metall mit
ein bisschen, bisschen
Leder-Zeug dran.
Okay, Moment, das muss ich jetzt gucken.
Diese... also wirklich.
Die sind... denen ist echt nicht mehr
zu helfen, ey.
Ausverkauft. Ausverkauft.
Wer kauft den Scheiß, Mann?
Beige de Weimar.
Alles klar.
Alter, es ist doch nicht euer
Ernst, Mann.
Also ich geb ja für gute Qualität und gute
Produkte auch durchaus Geld aus,
ja? Ja, ich hab mir beispielsweise
jetzt zum Rennen paar ordentliche Schuhe gekauft.
Die kosten auch zwischen 140 und 200 Euro,
je nachdem, wo man sie kauft und welche Ausstattung.
Aber WTF?
Ein... ein...
15 Gramm!
Petzen!
Ich muss mir jetzt mal angucken.
Ist das vielleicht größer, als ich mir das vorstelle?
Ja, gut, dass so ein China-Chinesen-
Anhänger 250 kostet, ist klar.
Ich will jetzt einfach mal wissen,
wie das aussieht.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
Ich will...
Es ist...
Es ist eine riesen, riesen Packung schon mal.
Eine riesen Packung für
ein bisschen... Ach, ne.
Eine riesen Packung für so ein
kleines Stück, Mann.
Ey, die tun ja so, als packen sie
gerade einen Goldbarren aus.
Who cares?
Das Essen... Das ist...
Verpackungsding.
Okay, so...
Das ist die AirTag
und...
Alter, was für eine riesen Verpackung
für so ein kleines Scheißding.
...
Ja, okay, weiter.
Das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Ja, Alter, reg dich ab.
Was geht mit dem Typ ab?
Alter, was ist los?
Wie lange will er da noch dran riechen, Mann?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Leute, Sekunde.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Man muss den Scheiß sogar noch selbst zusammenbauen, ja?
Das kommt doch nicht mal für dich zusammengebaut an.
Er muss das selbst zusammenbauen, ja?
Okay, Chat.
Das bräuchte ich nicht.
Ich muss das jetzt hinzufügen, Sekunde.
Wir brauchen das Emote.
So, hier.
Pepo Burn Money.
Was anderes fällt mir da echt gerade nicht mehr dazu ein.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was Adiletten sind.
Sind das Sandalen oder sowas, ja?
Pepo Burn Money.
Guckt mal an, Leute.
Guckt mal das Riesen-Package an.
Und dieses kleine Zeug.
5 Minuten.
Man, Luxury ist so weird.
Will er das auch gerade riechen, oder was?
Luxury ist so strange.
You sense the extra treatment.
And you can't help but feel special engaging with it.
Because you're like, this is so over the top.
Like, what do I do with this now?
What do I actually do with this?
I presume the AirTag is meant to be in use pretty much all the time.
So now I have...
It's nice, but it's amazing to see this much attention.
Okay.
Applied to something that you will experience for such a limited amount of time.
We figured this stuff out.
A necessary point of it.
Oh, interesting.
So you do a partial peel off the tag itself.
It triggers the battery and it comes to life.
For the Hermes.
This piece is gonna go through...
Ich finde es krass, Leute.
Dass man das selbst zusammenbauen muss.
The keyring goes on like a regular keyring, I guess.
Like this.
This is actually...
It's...
Okay.
And then this...
Comes over top of...
That's how it works.
Alter Leute, 400 Euro.
Das ist wirklich Pepo Burn Money.
Ich hab kein Problem, für hochwertige, qualitativ gute Sachen, auch für Werkzeug oder sowas,
Geld auszugeben.
Aber das im Leben nicht.
Das sieht nicht mal sonderlich geil aus, ja?
Ich muss das Frontchrom, das Chromedot zeigen.
Ich hatte das wahrscheinlich auch im Hintergrund.
Weil es...
Das heißt Hermes auf der einen Seite.
Ich muss es flippen.
Das ist oben.
AirTag-Broadcasting von vorne.
Das ist, wie...
Das ist, wie du...
Dein Hermes-AirTag machst.
Das Titel ist...
Das dürfen sie alle mal dran riechen, oder?
Okay.
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn.
So, wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache, Leute.
Hermes AirTag.
Okay.
Es sieht vielleicht nicht ganz so aus.
Aber es...
Ey, auf den ersten Blick...
Auf den ersten Blick sieht es doch schon relativ ähnlich aus.
Made in China, genau.
Es sieht schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Aber da steht nicht Hermes AirTag drauf, ja?
Da steht nur AirTag drauf.
Wisst ihr, Leute?
Ich glaube, da geht es überhaupt nicht darum, dass man was wirklich bekommt.
Sieht schon mal hier schepp genäht aus, aber okay.
Ich glaube, es geht bei dem Originalprodukt gar nicht so sehr da drauf.
Ähm, dass man wirklich was dafür bekommt, für das Geld.
Sondern es geht rein um Status.
Genauso wie, erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an diese, ähm, Ruby-App?
Äh, oder war das eine Diamant-App?
I am Rich, genau.
I am Rich-App.
Die gab es im App-Store zu kaufen für 1000 Dollar.
Und die App konnte nichts anderes, außer anzeigen,
anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen, anzeigen.
I am Rich.
Acht Leute haben die App gekauft.
Aber ich bin ja begeistert, dass du bei, beim China-Chinesen-Shop,
was bekommst, was genau so ausschaut.
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar noch das Gleiche, äh.
Okay, aber mal zurück zum eigentlichen Video.
Sonst wird das, sonst wird das heute echt, ich bin echt wieder, echt wieder schockiert, man.
Guckt ihr mal die Preise an.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich das Copy-Pasten, weil Twitch das wieder nicht gecheckt hat, ne.
Das sind Uhren, ja gut.
Alter.
Ja gut, da kann man sich natürlich so ein AirTag-Ding auch kaufen,
wenn du einfach 34.000 Euro für eine Uhr ausgeben kannst.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, ich hab meine, naja, im Vergleich zu dem billige Garmin-Uhr,
und die ist mir deutlich lieber, weil die mehr kann, von dem, was ich brauche.
Ja, die ist nicht mischanig.
Und die ist sicherlich keine so geile Wertanlage wie das vielleicht,
weiß ich nicht, kenne ich mich nicht mit aus, weiß nicht, ob die irgendwie ein paar Jahre noch was wert sind.
Aber, die kann meinen Puls messen, die kann aufzeichnen, ähm, am, äh, wie schnell ich renne, hat GPS drinne.
Kann unter anderem auch die Uhrzeit anzeigen, noch jede Menge anderes Zeug mehr.
Ich würde gar keine andere Uhr anziehen wollen.
Alter, die Preise sind echt nicht normal.
Was?
Wheels Kit.
Moment, die wollen, also Apple ist schon echt ein bisschen pepega, oder?
Die wollen 700 Dollar.
Ja, für ein paar Rollen haben, die man unter nem Mac machen kann.
Die kriegst du doch, die kriegst du doch bei AliExpress bei den China-Chinesen.
Garantiert auch für, okay, anscheinend nicht.
Was man die braucht?
Na, dass man sein, dass man sein Mac rollen kann.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Trägst du die Garmin mittlerweile auch nachts?
Nee, das ist mir zu unangenehm, ne Uhr nachts am Abend zu haben.
Und ich trage die tagsüber eigentlich auch nur, wenn ich auf der Arbeit bin, dann habe ich sie den ganzen Tag an.
Ansonsten habe ich sie nur an, wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich irgendwas mache.
Das heißt, die trackt bei mir auch nicht ganz richtig und Treppe hoch und Treppe runter trackt die auch nicht, aber wen juckt's.
19 Euro, dazu sage ich jetzt mal nichts.
So, jetzt aber noch zu den anderen Tags. Das TileMate nutzt sein eigenes Tile-Netzwerk und läuft auf Android und iOS, aber man muss dafür die Tile-App installiert haben.
Das Samsung Smart Tag benutzt das Samsung eigenes SmartThings-Netzwerk und läuft nur auf Samsung-Mobilgeräten ab Android 8.
Damit ihr mal ein Gefühl für die Pieper-Lautstärke bekommt, haben wir die vier Tags mal nacheinander piepsen lassen.
Das Audio ist unbearbeitet.
Das ist, das ist Tile, glaube ich, der letzte hier.
Das ist Tile, glaube ich zumindest, weil von denen hatte ich auch mal ein Gerät und es hat sich so ähnlich angehört.
So, und jetzt noch zum Thema GPS-Tracker.
Steht das dran? Echt, wo?
Ah ja, ah, das ist recht, okay.
So, und jetzt noch zum Thema GPS-Tracker.
Ja, ja, es gibt echte GPS-Tracker für Fahrräder.
Nur brauchen die halt eine Mobilfunk-Datenverbindung, damit sie ihre Position selbst ins Netz schicken können.
Also ohne Umweg über andere Smartphones.
Das benötigt sehr viel Energie.
Deutlich mehr als das Bluetooth-Leuchtfeuer der kleinen Findetags.
Und ja, man braucht natürlich für Mobilfunk-Daten eigentlich auch einen Mobilfunk-Vertrag und eine SIM-Karte.
Es gibt aber inzwischen so GPS-Tracker, da ist das alles integriert, aber das Energie-Problem bleibt.
Hier zum Beispiel der Cobblestone von Copenhagen-Trackers kostet 100 Euro und hat eine fest eingebaute Batterie.
Ja, und...
KR, was sind das? Dänische Kronen, oder?
Ja, wenn man häufig die Position ins Netz senden will, ist die nach wenigen Monaten oder sogar Wochen...
...ist die nach wenigen Monaten oder sogar Wochen...
...leer.
Der Hersteller verspricht, dass die Batterie vier Jahre lang hält, wenn man lediglich einmal am Tag die Position sendet.
Aber A ist einmal am Tag meiner Meinung nach viel zu wenig, um das Fahrrad nach einem Diebstahl zuverlässig aufzuspüren.
Und B stimmt die Angabe zumindest laut Kundenbewertung nicht.
In der Praxis ist das Ding oft wohl früher leer.
Zum Vergleich, drei der von uns hier getesteten Bluetooth-Findetags nutzen Standard-Batterien.
Nämlich CR2032-Knopfzellen, die kosten 50 Cent.
Das ist dies nur nach 15 Dingen, was überall reinkommt.
Was in Autoschlüssel reinkommt, in teilweise Fernbedienung reinkommt.
Das ist so, glaube ich, so mit die meistbenutzte Knopfzelle, die es so gibt.
Und die halten ungefähr ein Jahr lang, was wir auch bestätigen können.
Nur der Teil hat eine festintegrierte Batterie.
Es gibt Teils aber auch etwas teurer mit Wechselbrandbatterien.
Also jedenfalls kein Wunder, dass zum Beispiel die deutsche Firma SAR Mini, die früher noch einen GPS-Tracker angeboten haben...
...inzwischen komplett auf...
Ey, haben die das Gnome-Logo geklaut?
SAR Mini...
Das sieht aus wie das Gnome-Logo.
Naja...
Bisschen.
Aber der hat 5, guck mal, der hat 15, Gnome hat nur 14.
...die, die früher noch einen GPS-Tracker angeboten haben, inzwischen komplett auf AirTags umgestiegen sind.
Weil das einfach viel effizienter und praktischer ist.
So, und jetzt aber wieder zu unserem...
Er ist ja gut am Schwitzen beim Video aufnehmen gerade.
...Experiment.
Wir haben also alle vier Tracker in Gang gesetzt und mit kompatiblen Smartphones gekoppelt.
Dabei muss ich echt mal Apple loben.
Ich war ziemlich beeindruckt, wie unglaublich einfach man einen AirTag aktiviert.
Aus der Packung nehmen wir hier die...
...Lasche von der Batterie wegziehen und zack, sofort poppt auf meinem in der Nähe liegenden iPhone...
Ja, das können sie.
Einmal auf Verbinden tippen, fertig.
Beim billig AirTag ging das nicht ganz so leicht.
Das größte Problem war die Batterielasche, die ich da fast nicht abgezogen bekommen habe.
Man muss das Teil allerdings auch manuell koppeln mit der Wo-Ist-App.
Ja, aber das hat auch schnell funktioniert.
Bei Samsung und Teil dagegen verlief die Einrichtung komplizierter.
Vor allem, weil man bei beiden erst Accounts beim Hersteller anlegen muss.
Aber gut, man richtet die Dinger ja auch nur einmal ein.
Und dann...
Also ans Fahrrad damit.
Für den Apple AirTag kann man so eine super unauffällige Klingel kaufen.
AirBell heißt die, wo man den AirTag einfach unten reinsetzt.
Kostet 18 Euro und gefällt mir echt richtig gut, weil man das wirklich von außen...
Ganz ehrlich, jeder Fahrraddieb weiß wahrscheinlich, dass es diese Klingel gibt und reißt die als erstes ab.
...außen absolut nicht erkennen kann.
Die anderen Tags habe ich mit der bewährten Panzertape-Methode eingebaut.
Der Plan ging jetzt folgendermaßen.
Lukas fährt mit meinem Fahrrad irgendwo hin und ich versuche ihn nur...
...mit den Tags am Rad zu finden.
Damit Lukas nicht selbst die Bluetooth-Signale der Tags auffängt, hat er keinerlei Technik dabei, außer seiner analogen Armbanduhr.
Ja, und los geht's. Um 13.10 Uhr fährt Lukas los.
Ich bin jetzt eine halbe Stunde vom Verlag weggefahren, hab mich hier mitten in den Stadtwald irgendwo begeben.
Und bisher habe ich ungefähr zehn Fahrradfahrer gesehen und zwei Fußgänger, die hier vorbeigegangen sind.
Eine davon hat ein Handy in der Hand.
Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es irgendwie einer von den Trackern hier jetzt angesprungen ist, ist auf jeden Fall da.
Aber ob Keno mich am Ende wirklich findet oder nicht, ja, schauen wir mal, was wird.
Um 14.00 Uhr beginne ich dann, ihn zu suchen.
Ich gucke jetzt zum ersten Mal in die Apps rein und gucke, was da...
J-Law, das ist eigentlich eine richtige Five-Hand-Idee, oder?
Man versteckt zwei AirTags im Sitz und macht sich so eine Fake-Klingel dran.
Also man macht sich eine AirTag-Klingel dran, in die man gar keinen AirTag reinmacht.
Und jeder Dieb denkt dann, die AirTags sind in der Klingel.
Ja.
Pfeifert.
Also passiert ist, ob ich Lukas finden kann, beziehungsweise mein Fahrrad.
Ich fange an mit der Teil-App, weil ich der ehrlich gesagt die geringsten Chancen ausrechne.
Aha.
Hä?
Nee.
Okay, ach, das ist hier die Timeline.
Okay, das ist die Timeline.
Das ist einfach mein Weg, den ich zur Arbeit gefahren bin.
Das heißt, es hat keinen Standort.
So, ich habe das Ding jetzt quasi als verloren gemeldet.
Ja, bringt nichts.
So, jetzt probiere ich mal Samsung aus, also die Samsung-Find-App mit den SmartTags.
Mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm.
Letzte Aktualisierung.
Das ist halt, das ist das, was ich am Anfang gemeint habe.
Das ist halt der Riesenvorteil von AirTags.
Jedes iPhone schickt es weiter.
Vor einer Stunde.
Und auch der Standortverlauf zeigt mir nichts an.
Jetzt kommen wir zum AirTag von Apple.
Wir fangen mal mit dem Billig-AirTag an.
So, wo ist...
Uh!
Ich stehe hier vor Heise, ne, seht ihr ja.
Aber mein Fahrrad ist angeblich ein kleines bisschen weiter in der Karl-Wichert-Allee 15.
Ist jetzt aber mal gar nicht so weit entfernt.
Ja, ziemlich unbefriedigend.
Teil und Samsung zeigen immer noch den Ausgangspunkt an, das Heise-Verlagshaus.
Der AirTag zeigt einen Ort nur ein paar hundert Meter weiter an.
Das wird nicht Lukas Versteck sein, aber ich fahre da trotzdem mal hin.
Also ja, da hat er sich nicht versteckt.
Aber hier ist ein Studentenwohnheim, deshalb ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß,
dass hier jemand das AirTag-Funkfeuer aufgefangen hat, denke ich mir zumindest.
Nach ein bisschen Warterei fahre ich mal in den Wald, in die Eilenriede, angeblich Europas größter Stadtwald.
Zumindest würde ich da an so einem heißen Tag wie heute hinfahren, da ist es nämlich schön kühl.
So, wo ist...
Zuletzt gesehen um 13.16 Uhr, also sechs Minuten, nachdem er losgefahren ist.
Jetzt ist es 14.48 Uhr, ich glaube nicht mehr dran.
Ich gucke nochmal an Teil und bei Teil hat sich ebenfalls gar nichts getan.
Und jetzt nochmal Samsung.
Letzte Aktualisierung vor zwei Stunden.
Wieso fährt er random irgendwo hin?
Du meinst er? Naja.
Gucken, ob er vielleicht einen Empfang kriegt.
Standortverlauf auch.
Samsung hat nicht mal mitbekommen, dass Lukas sich vom Verlag wegbewegt hat.
Ja, aber keine Chance.
Die Eilenriede ist viel zu groß, um Lukas und mein Fahrrad ohne Hilfsmittel zu finden.
Ich lasse mal meine Drohne steigen, vielleicht sehe ich ihn da von oben.
Nee, leider nicht.
Um 15 Uhr, also fast zwei Stunden nachdem Lukas losgefahren ist,
fahre ich wieder ins Büro.
Das AirTag zeigt immer noch die letzte Position um 13.16 Uhr an,
also da am Schlindenwohnheim.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich suchen soll.
Es sind jetzt auch wirklich einige Leute an mir vorbeigelaufen,
die irgendwie Smartphones in der Hand hatten.
Mindestens drei iPhones habe ich gezählt.
Zwei davon hatten auch noch eine Portion in den Ohren.
Das heißt, AirTag ist sinnlos.
Er kommt darauf an, wie du das verwenden willst.
Also zum Fahrrad tracken, wenn es geklaut ist, geht sicherlich.
Ja, musst halt ein bisschen Glück haben.
Also wo das wahrscheinlich funktioniert ist,
ist, dass ich das Fahrrad nicht mehr verwenden kann.
Also, wenn ich das Fahrrad nicht mehr verwenden kann,
dann muss ich das Fahrrad nicht mehr verwenden.
Wenn das Fahrrad geklaut wird
und da steht ein Tag irgendwo in der Scheune rum
und irgendwann läuft mal zufällig einer vorbei
und fängt das auf und schickt es weiter, ja.
Aber so Live-Tracking innerhalb kurzer Zeit dafür,
also man sieht ja dafür, wofür es auch nicht geeignet ist,
zum Beispiel um Haustiere zu tracken und sowas,
kannst du komplett knicken.
Also definitiv auch Bluetooth an.
Also der AirTag zumindest muss eigentlich angeschlagen haben.
Also wenn Keno mich jetzt nicht,
wenn ich jetzt nicht, wenn ich jetzt nicht,
dann kein gutes Zeichen.
Um 15.39 Uhr dann jetzt die Sensation.
Jetzt gerade habe ich ein Update bekommen in Woist.
In den anderen beiden Apps ist nach wie vor nichts zu sehen.
Da ist das Fahrrad gar nicht von hier weggekommen.
Aber ich habe jetzt einen neuen Ort.
Kurioserweise sind die Positionen laut Woist von 14.04 Uhr und 14.05 Uhr.
Also offenbar hat das System eine Verzögerung von anderthalb Stunden.
Warum das denn? Seltsam.
Aber ich fahre dahin in der Hoffnung,
dass Lukas noch nicht aufgegeben hat.
Leute, ist das aufwendig.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ja, da sitzt er wirklich auf der Bank und liest ein analoges Buch.
Es hat geklappt, aber halt erst drei Stunden,
nachdem mein Fahrrad geklaut wurde.
Lukas hat mir dann erzählt, dass viele Leute an ihm vorbeispaziert sind.
Einige auch mit Airpods im Ohr.
Die müssen also ziemlich sicher sein Signal aufgefangen haben.
Aber war da wirklich niemand mit Samsung Handy dabei?
Die Samsung App zeigt nämlich immer noch den alten Ohr.
Teil auch.
Okay, das Experiment hat also funktioniert,
aber durch die Verzögerung beim AirTag
ziemlich unbefriedigend und vor allem will ich nicht glauben,
dass Samsung...
Also der Rest, ich dachte mir es irgendwie schon,
dass das Einzige, was halbwegs funktioniert, die AirTags sind.
... und Teil gar nicht funktionieren.
Deshalb habe ich dann Lukas gebeten, noch mal mein Rad zu klauen
und damit in eine belebtere Umgebung mitten in der Stadt zu fahren.
Ich bin jetzt auch hier in einer belebten Ecke in Hannover
und ich versuche, ihn jetzt zu finden.
Ja, und das Ergebnis ist etwas besser.
Die beiden AirTags haben deutlich schneller die Fährte aufgenommen.
Samsung etwas später auch, aber Teil hat mal wieder gar nicht funktioniert.
Naja, es liegt vermutlich daran, dass das auch über Träger-Smartphones
zwingend die Teil-App installiert sein muss und offenbar ist das
auch nur sehr wenigen Handys der Fall.
Bevor ich zum Fazit komme, muss ich unbedingt noch mal
über das Missbrauchspotenzial der Tags sprechen.
Sowohl Teil als auch Samsung können einen Standortverlauf anlegen.
Bei Teil kostet das extra, man muss ein Abo für 35 Euro im Jahr abschließen.
Geil, ein Abo abschließen für die einzige App,
die nicht funktioniert, sehr gute Idee.
Ich will nicht genau sehen, wann das Bluetooth-Tag wo war.
Und zwar auch dann, wenn die Person, die das Ding mit sich rumschleppt,
gar nicht weiß, dass es da ist.
Also wenn das zum Beispiel unter das Auto geklebt ist
oder in eine Handtasche eingenäht.
Man bekommt bei Samsung und Teil tatsächlich auch keine Warnmeldung
aufs Handy. Wir haben das ausprobiert.
Lukas hat alle auf meine Accounts aktivierten Tags zwei Tage
mit sich rumgeschleppt.
Nur bei den beiden AirTags hat die Warnung funktioniert, aber auch nur
auf Lukas iPhone, auf seinem Android-Telefon, einem Pixel 7,
das auch schon das fremde AirTags erkennen Update bekommen hat, nicht.
Also zumindest nicht automatisch, als er manuell, man kann da manuell
nach fremden Tags suchen, da hat er das erkannt.
Aber ich meine, man kann ja nicht ständig nach Tags suchen.
Wenn das der Fall ist, will ich ein Popup kriegen.
So bringt es ja nicht viel.
Auf dem iPhone bekamen wir übrigens die Du führst ein unbekanntes AirTag Meldung,
immer wenn wir in die Nähe unserer Wohnung kamen.
Das scheint Apple bewusst so eingerichtet zu haben.
Schließlich will man
nicht, dass Stalker wissen, wo man wohnt.
Man kann also, bevor man in die Wohnung geht, schnell woanders hingehen,
das Feind AirTag suchen und die Batterie rausnehmen.
Wie das geht, zeigt die Warnmeldung auf dem iPhone auch direkt an.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt jetzt.
Das ist echt ganz gut gemacht.
Aber wie gesagt, bei Tile und Samsung gibt es keinerlei Warnung.
Nun kann man sagen, zum Glück funktionieren
deren beiden Suchnetzwerke nicht so gut wie das von Apple.
Aber zumindest die Samsung Tags dürfen in größeren Städten
für illegale Anwendungen echt nutzbar sein.
Laut Samsung würde
die Smart Things App auf Samsung Geräten fremde Smart Tags erkennen.
Aber das nützt nun wenig, wenn man selbst keine Samsung Mobilgerät verwendet.
Man kann ja nicht immer als Schutz noch irgendwie ein Samsung Phone mitnehmen.
Apple und Google haben das Problem zumindest erkannt
und sich auf einen Stalker Warnstandard geeinigt.
Damit sollen iOS und Android standardmäßig fremde Findetags erkennen.
Wir können aber Stand heute sagen, ein Pixel 7 mit aktuellen...
Es wäre natürlich cool, wenn die das nicht nur erkennen,
sondern auch weiterleiten können.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn Android und Apple,
das weiterleiten, da wäre das Netzwerk doch deutlich dichter.
Aber das werden die nicht wollen.
Android erkennt automatisch kein einziges unserer vier Tags.
iPhones erkennen zumindest fremde AirTags automatisch,
aber kein Samsung und kein Tile.
Das ist echt problematisch und sollte schleunigst behoben werden.
Wichtig ist vor allem, dass Samsung und Tile mit Apple und Google
bei ihrem gemeinsamen Standard zusammenarbeiten.
Interesse haben sie zumindest schon bekundet.
Wir werden uns die Situation ein paar Monate noch mal angucken,
weil zumindest ich will ungern
heimlich getrackt werden.
Das geht euch wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Apropos Standard, Google plant auch,
ein geräteübergreifendes Android-Finde-Netzwerk zu etablieren,
was dann so wie das von Apple funktionieren soll,
dass also jedes Android-Telefon auf Betriebssystem-Ebene
Findetags erkennt und die Position weitergibt.
Aber irgendwie wurde das immer wieder nach hinten verschoben.
Mal sehen, wann das Projekt startet.
Im besten Fall aber dürfte das neue Android-Finde-Netzwerk dann zumindest...
Das wird dann innerhalb, wenn es nicht gut ankommt,
gleich auf den Friedhof wieder geschmissen von Google.
Google... Gibt's ja diese Seite hier, Killed by Google,
wo alles draufsteht, was Google bisher rausgebracht hat und eingestellt hat.
Ist schon ein bisschen was.
Vieles hat man noch gar nicht gehört.
Ja, ich weiß zum Beispiel nicht, was Grasshopper ist.
Oder CheckHard.
Chacquard, wie auch immer.
Google Domains erst letztens, ja.
Ich finde es hierzulande sogar besser funktionieren als das
Wo-ist-Netzwerk.
Ich finde es auch besser, als das von Apple.
Denn in der deutschsprachigen Welt hat Android einen höheren Marktanteil als Apple.
In der Schweiz ist der Apple-Anteil zwar sehr hoch,
aber Androids gibt es hier noch ein bisschen mehr.
Am schönsten wäre natürlich auch hier ein Apple- und Google-Übergreifungs-Netzwerk.
Ja, das wäre cool, aber da haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Aber das wird wohl nicht passieren.
Da denken die Firmen leider mehr ans Geld als an ihre Kundschaft.
Mein Fazit.
Ja, es funktioniert.
Man kann ohne GPS-Tracker ein geklautes Fahrrad wiederfinden.
Am besten klappt das mit AirTags.
Man kann da auch getrost die billigere Wo-ist-Kompatible nicht Apple-Geräte nehmen.
Die gehen genauso gut.
Aber man muss ihm klar sein, wenn das Fahrrad irgendwo im Niemandsland ist,
wo nie jemand mit iPhone vorbeiläuft, dann hat man ein Problem.
Und man muss die Verzögerung auf dem Schirm haben,
bis das Fahrrad dann endlich in der Wo-ist-App auftaucht.
Dauert halt ein bisschen.
Die Tags von Samsung funktionieren leider nur in extrem belebten Umgebungen.
Und der Teil hat zumindest bei unseren Tests gar nicht funktioniert.
Also das Teil-Netzwerk.
Aber Hauptsache mal ein Abo für abschließen.
Klingel auf jeden Fall am Lenker lassen.
Und schlafe damit jetzt auch ein bisschen ruhiger als vorher.
Tschüss.
See you.
Ja, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also falls jemand da mit auf die Idee kommt, sein Haustier zu tracken oder sowas, könnte knicken.
Für Echtzeit ist das schon mal gar nix.
Du vergrabst, du vergräbst den AirTag im Garten.
Du meinst, falls einer deinen Garten klaut?
Was kostet ein Einfamilienhaus?
Wahrscheinlich viel zu viel, als dass es sich wirklich lohnt.
Gaben!
Ist das nicht der alte Mac Pro, der aussah wie ein Aschenbecher?
War heute schon C++-Rent?
Nein.
Das muss jeder mit dem Geschirrspüler machen.
Nein, das müssen wir nicht machen mit dem Geschirrspüler.
Was haben wir denn als nächstes?
BUN is disrupting the Javascript-Land.
Komm, wir gucken eine Runde Fireship.
Fireship waren immer gute Videos.
Was disrupted BUN?
Ich habe letztens gesehen, dass BUN Version 1.0 da ist.
Ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch, ob die Welt das alles gebraucht hat.
Aber schauen wir mal.
Was Localhost-Unterschied.
127001.
Das eine ist noch nicht mal eine gültige IP-Adresse.
Und das eine ist zumindest meistens Localhost.
Algorithmen verstehen.
Dann verstehen wir vielleicht auch, was der Unterschied ist.
Jetzt gucken wir erst mal, was Fireship erzählt.
... 2023 and you're watching the Code Report.
Yesterday was a huge day for Soy Devs.
Mojo became generally available.
A super set of Python that's up to 35,000 times faster.
Haben wir schon gesehen.
But Javascript also got way faster.
Thanks to a new Swiss Army knife called BUN.
And that means it's time for some new stickers on my MacBook Pro.
Javascript developers have grown tired of reinventing new frameworks.
So now we're building entirely new Javascript runtimes.
In the beginning we had Node.js.
Then rearranged the letters to make Deno.
And now we've got BUN fresh out of the oven.
Which just hit 1.0 this morning.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde eigentlich,
also bei Node.js ist immer noch mit Abstand das Verbreitetste.
Was ich bei Deno nicht gecheckt habe am Anfang ist,
dass sie gesagt haben, sie unterstützen kein NPM.
Oder keine Packages.
Also das ist ja quasi eines der größten Vorteile des Javascript Ökosystems,
dass es für alles und jedes und was es überhaupt gibt, irgendein Package gibt.
Ich mein, im Javascript Land gibt es tatsächlich Packages für,
ob eine Zahl gerade oder ungerade ist.
Und um nicht zu vergessen, es gibt ein Package, das sich nennt is-odd.
Und dann gibt es ein Package, das sich nennt is-is-odd.
Und es gibt auch ein Package, was sich nennt is-even.
Und diese Packages werden eine halbe Million mal in der Woche,
okay, das hier nicht.
Eine halbe Million und eine Viertelmillion mal runtergeladen in der Woche.
Immer noch.
Und jetzt haltet euch mal fest, wer jetzt denkt, das sind real Packages.
Und wer jetzt etwa denkt, das ist sogar archived mittlerweile.
Und wenn man sich den Code anguckt, das ist alles.
Also dafür braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Übrigens is-even importiert das andere Modul is-odd.
Da hat man schon mal zwei Abhängigkeiten für.
Warum macht man das, kann man doch mit Modulu rausfinden.
Ja, macht er ja auch hier.
Aber vorher guckt er noch,
ob das eine Nummer ist, eine Zahl und was überhaupt so.
Ja.
Warum just JavaScript things?
You know, and now we've got Bun fresh out of the oven,
which just hit 1.0 this morning.
And you should take notice, because it can run your JavaScript code
faster than any other tool known to man.
But not just that, it also acts as a bundler like Webpack or Vite,
a test runner like Jest or Karma,
and a package manager like NPM or Yarn.
Kann Bun NPM-Packages verwenden? Wahrscheinlich nicht, ja.
Oh doch!
But has its own set of highly optimized APIs
that actually make it fun to build high-performance
server-side applications with JavaScript.
Before we get into it though, I want to show you
another awesome new tool from our sponsor, DevGPT.
By now you've heard of tools like ChatGPT and Copilot,
but DevGPT takes AI code generation to the next level
by integrating directly with your own code generation
with your own code generation.
Also, DevGPT is a tool,
by integrating directly with your Git repo,
giving the AI the full context of your tech stack and project.
After writing a prompt to fix a bug or create a feature,
it'll ask follow-up questions
to write highly targeted and useful code.
Once the code is generated,
you can then sync those changes to your local project instantly.
Then you could prompt it to generate some unit tests
to validate that code.
It's like having an automated engineer by your side
who can take care of your GitHub issues
and Jira tickets instantly without complaining.
You can try it out for free yourself right now
with the link below.
But now let's get back to Bunn.
First of all, how do they make this thing so fast?
One major difference compared to Node and Deno,
which uses the V8 engine from Chrome,
Bunn uses JavaScript Core from Safari,
which is known to be optimized...
Stimmt, das ist, das ist, ähm...
Das ist ja nicht V8.
Das ist WebKit-JavaScript-Zeusch, ja.
...the V8 engine from Chrome,
Bunn uses JavaScript Core from Safari,
which is known to be optimized
for startup times.
In addition, Bunn is implemented
in the Zig programming language.
They've put a focus on profiling performance bottlenecks
and implement APIs in native code.
The end result is a hella world with TypeScript
that's five times faster than ESBuild.
Keep in mind, though, benchmarks can always be cherry-picked
and rarely reflect real-world performance.
It's fun to go fast, but because I...
...only have 12 monthly active users on my website,
it doesn't make a huge difference for me.
What I care about is the developer experience.
Can Bunn make my life easier?
It's got awesome TypeScript support out of the box.
You can immediately start writing TypeScript code
without any configuration or headaches.
And it also supports JSX and hot reloading,
which means you don't need any weird dependencies
like Node, Mon, and Concurrently
to recompile your code when things change.
That's cool, but one of the absolute worst things about Node
has been the transition from common JS
to ES modules.
What's cool about Bunn is that you can just use
import and require in the same file
and everything just magically works.
And it's compatible with existing Node.js packages,
which means you don't have to reinvent the wheel
every little thing you want to implement.
Deno also added NPM support as well recently,
but what I really like about Bunn is its native APIs.
For example, to read and write to the file system,
we can access the global Bunn runtime
and make a reference to a file,
then lazily read it or parse its JSON.
That may not seem like a big deal,
but in Node.js there are three different ways
to do the same thing.
Read file with callbacks,
read file with promises,
or read file sync.
You can actually use all of those in Bunn,
but not only are the native APIs faster,
but you can also do the same thing.
Import is the ES6 syntax,
also the official JavaScript syntax,
and require was what Node.js came up with
before there was import.
That's why they changed it to the official one.
But Node.js has been using require for years,
because there were no official JavaScript modules.
In principle, they do the same thing.
Certainly not in detail,
but there is a lot of work to be done
to make sure that it works.
In the end, it's just a matter of time
until you get to the point
where you can actually use it.
In addition, it's extremely easy
to set up an HTTP server in Bunn
by simply calling the serve method.
You then use familiar...
Ja, gut, ich finde,
das ist überhaupt kein Pluspunkt mehr,
weil in jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache
kannst du so was heutzutage machen.
Du kannst sogar in C-Sharp
mittlerweile ein Web-API-Projekt starten
mit drei Zeilen Code.
Das ist wirklich kein tolles Neues mehr.
Browser primitive
wie Fetch und Response
um deine API zu bauen.
Das bringt dich ziemlich weit.
Aber es gibt auch Frameworks, die mit Bunn arbeiten,
wie Elysia, die 18-mal schneller ist
als ExpressJS und Node.
Bunn arbeitet auch mit Hano,
das ist mein go-to-Framework für APIs.
Bunn hat auch viele andere Simplifikationen.
Vergeht eigentlich irgendwie mal
zwei Wochen im JavaScript-Land,
bis es nicht irgendwie mal
ein neues gehyptes Framework für irgendwas gibt?
Wobei man sagen muss,
wenn man sich das so anguckt,
so viel Bewegung ist ja da die letzten Jahre,
ist immer noch drinnen, aber
im Vergleich zu früher relativ konstant.
React ist weiterhin vorne.
Enterprise-Business-Scheiß
verwendet immer noch ganz gerne Angular.
Vue ist auch noch irgendwie da.
Es kam noch Svelte dazu.
Plus so ein paar Abkömmlinge.
Du hast da noch sowas wie
Solid und
für die ganzen React-Fans.
Dann hast du noch
wie heißt das andere jetzt?
HTX oder sowas, was jetzt neu
dazugekommen ist für eigentlich nur
HTML mit ein bisschen Javascript.
Dann,
was gibt's denn sonst noch so?
Fällt mir jetzt grad nichts mehr ein.
Astro gibt's noch.
Was? React ist jetzt nicht
mehr angesagt. SAP, ja.
Nice. Angular hatte ich schon.
Cool, but as the name implies,
Bun is also a bundler.
The Bun build command will take all your source files
and then combine them into a single output
that can be used in a browser.
And based on this benchmark, it's pretty amazing
how much faster things have gotten
just since Webpack 5 a couple years ago.
Oh, and another really cool thing is that
Bun has a SQLite database built directly into the runtime.
It's incredibly convenient to have a relational database
without the need to install and configure a bunch of drivers.
Another thing we need to talk about though
is the Bun Package Manager.
It's actually a standalone tool that can be used
in any Node.js project today.
If you want to make things go faster right now,
replace npx with a command like
bunx cowsay hello world,
which allows you to save a few precious milliseconds
when saying hi to your mom.
Which is important, because you never know
how much time you have left to do that.
This has been The Code Report, thanks for watching,
and I will see you in the next one.
Tja, jetzt wissen wir, dass wir demnächst mal
Bun verwenden müssen. Was bin ich hier sehend?
Let me know if this has ever happened to you.
You feel like you finally know
how to use pointers.
Niemand mastered C++.
...uses pointers, maybe you use the heap,
maybe you don't. You run your code
and it still crashes anyways.
Das ist normal, das ist C++.
You check the syntax of your code
and the syntax is definitely right,
but something about the code isn't.
Now, all because you know how to use pointers
doesn't mean you're using them correctly.
And it's actually...
Niemand weiß, wie man C++ correctly verwendet.
Das weiß ja noch nicht mal
die Leute, die den C++ standen.
Die wollen eigentlich nicht
in C++, in C++ standards entwerfen,
sonst würden sie nicht immer widersprüchliche Sachen
da reinbauen.
...really really easy to mess up raw pointers.
...schon das PHP Video gesehen.
Moment, DAS PHP Video.
Was ist DAS PHP Video?
Du meinst von, von...
Ich weiß nicht, wir haben letztens ein PHP Video gesehen,
dass PHP gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Und da muss ich zustimmen, das, was ich gesehen habe,
fand ich eigentlich ganz gut durchdacht
im Vergleich zu neuen C++ Standards.
...C++.
piece of code hier ich sehe nur dass es hässlich wie die nacht ist zumal das ja auch eigentlich
reines c ist und kein c++ oder ich sehe ich sehe hier nichts c++ sie ist dran wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich ist das auch der der der aufhänger von ihm was er jetzt erzählen möchte du sie der
bach weil eins endlos schleife 128 print f tja ich weiß nicht was aus und service ist aus und
service ist halt nirgends wo angelegt keine ahnung wo das herkommt jetzt ist immer so ein ding da
weiß ich nie ob es funktioniert oder nicht das buch has a use after freeborder ability
we're on this line here the code get freed but later on the logic
ist
, das einfach unnötig kompliziert ist und auch vieles fehlt es gibt immer noch kein
http klein trainer in c++ in der c++ standard library
ist ein fettenspartner auf mein ich meine wir brauchen heutzutage schon http ist komplett
abbreвet niemand braucht ttp man benutzt schon das internet beständige Babsequenzen
ein super
machen man auch selbst machen man kann auch einfach alles inne verblocken kann alles irgendwie selbst
machen dann hast du aber wieder irgendwann party
Library, wo wir wieder das Problem haben,
30 Milliarden Header-Kacke in C++
zu haben, anstatt
ordentliche Module. Und ob sich C++-Module
jemals durchsetzen, sei mal
dahingestellt.
By the way, ich finde auch
diese Objektsyntax in C++
so hässlich.
Äh, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Und gerade, also, was mich
am meisten triggert immer noch, ist ja diese
Output-Formatierung, die
nicht vorhandene. Wobei es mittlerweile
Standard-Format gibt, das haben sie aus
Python abgerippt. Das funktioniert
wenigstens halbwegs. Aber das ist wirklich
abfuck, ey, wenn ich sowas schon sehe, man.
Guck mal, der hat, der hat
seine, seine
Logik. Ne, vergiss es.
Und dann später nennen wir die Funktion
DoSomethingWithTheDog, wo wir
sagen, das letzte Objekt, setze
sein Name zu HiHi und dann
spreche. Also, wenn wir das hier kompilen können,
können wir es kompilen und es runnen.
Und es funktioniert, wie erwartet,
ohne Probleme bis jetzt. Aber was,
wenn es Logik in diesem Code gäbe, wo wir
etwas zu dem Hund tun würden,
und am Ende sagen wir, delete
die. Aber später auf dem Code,
wenn wir über den Hund sprechen, oder etwas
anderes, oder etwas außerhalb
dieser Funktion,
okay, was will er uns eigentlich sagen?
Ah, Standard Unique, oh,
oh, diese, diese Syntax,
die ist so,
so grandios
toll.
Ich sag nur Standard Vector Bool.
Ich kann die Language einfach nicht
ab, ey.
Was ist das?
Gekommen wir jetzt am Start?
Chainlord, was schickst du mir hier für komische Videos?
Und was zum Teufel ist mit dem seinem Mikro los?
Was auch immer.
Alter, Chainlord, hör auf, mir so einen Kack zu schicken.
Er ist immer Content Creator.
Ich verstehe nicht, wer das frei...
Also, ich, doch, ich verstehe es.
Manchmal hast du keine Alternative.
Also, wenn du Microcontroller-Zeug machst,
und es halt vieles nur in C&C++ gibt,
okay, oder, ähm,
ja, wenn du irgendwelche Unreal
Innereien bauen willst,
ja, da kommst du nicht drumherum, okay,
aber für alles andere, äh,
frei will ich nicht.
Haben wir schon oft genug gemacht, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Diese Woche zum ersten Mal PowerShell.
PowerShell ist tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht,
PowerShell ist echt okay.
PowerShell ist super zum Automatisieren,
aber interaktiv finde ich PowerShell
nicht schön zu benutzen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Dieses Haus ist 200.000 Euro teurer als geplant.
Ja, Haus bauen ist teuer as fuck.
Deswegen bin ich froh,
dass ich kein Haus bauen musste,
sondern das Haus vom Opa geerbt habe.
Weil das Umbauen war,
beziehungsweise ich hab's ja gar nicht direkt geerbt.
Ähm, aber das, das,
das Renovieren war schon,
das war schon ein bisschen,
auch nicht billig,
aber nicht so,
mit Sicherheit nicht so teuer,
wie ein eigenes Haus bauen.
Okay, jetzt hat man ja 3 Minuten 56.
Ist das wirklich der private finanzielle Ruin,
was wir hier machen,
oder können wir es mit einem Leben
wirklich nur abzahlen?
Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich könnt ihr es abbezahlen,
wenn es so weiterläuft,
wie ihr das denkt.
Die denken nämlich so nach dem Motto,
wir bleiben für immer zusammen
und wir bleiben auch immer hier wohnen
und wir werden hier
alle mal 85
und 85
und alle sind happy für immer.
Das klappt dann bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht,
bis sie keinen Bock mehr aufeinander haben
und sich nach 3 Jahren trennen
und dann irgendjemand den Scheiß bezahlen muss.
Und selbst dann,
also ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit,
also auf der alten Arbeit,
hab ich euch ja erzählt,
hat ein Haus,
hat, hat sich jetzt ein Haus gekauft,
beziehungsweise Haus bauen oder was auch immer,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob man ein fertiges gekauft hat
oder eins bauen wollte.
Und der hat gesagt, der bezahlt jetzt 30 Jahre lang ab.
Der ist ein bisschen jünger als ich,
sagen wir mal, der ist 30.
Der bezahlt bis 30 Jahre, Alter.
30 Jahre.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was in 5 Jahren ist.
Ich hab doch keine Ahnung, was in fucking 30 Jahren ist, Mann.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Emo.
Okay.
Ein Haus zu bauen.
Mein Traum ist es definitiv nie gewesen, ein Haus zu bauen.
Generell Sachen mit körperlicher Arbeit auf der Baustelle.
Nee, nee.
Es gibt Tage, wo ich es bereue.
Und es gibt Tage, wo ich sage, ja, ich freu mich auf den Einzug.
Abbezahlen ist heutzutage auch billiger als Mieten.
Also ich hab letztens einen Artikel drüber gelesen.
Ihr wisst, dass ich von solchen Finanzsachen keine große Ahnung habe.
Aber in dem Artikel stand sinngemäß drinne,
dass es sich ja theoretisch lohnen würde,
quasi die, auf die Miete zu verzichten,
also das, was man als Miete bezahlt,
zu nehmen als Finanzierung für ein Haus.
Und so hat man quasi das, sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen,
das Gleiche bezahlt,
nach 30 Jahren, wie wenn man in Miete wohnt.
Aber man hat am Ende ein Haus.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es in Deutschland nicht richtig funktionieren würde.
Ich kann euch aber nicht sagen, warum.
So, lasst uns mal angucken.
Ich war wirklich froh,
dass wir bei dem Renovieren hier einen Architekt dabei hatten,
der täglich auf die Baustelle ist, geguckt hat.
Und dass wir wirklich wenig machen mussten.
Ich hab so keinen Bock.
Ich hab schon gekotzt, wo wir hier teilweise Tapete abmachen mussten.
Und das Geilste, also,
eines der geilsten Sachen beim Renovieren,
das weiß ich noch,
das wollte ich euch jetzt an der Stelle mal kurz erzählen,
das war,
am Montag
kommt der Typ,
um Kacheln an die Wand zu machen im Bad.
So, und
der Typ, der verputzt hat die Wände,
der ist aber zu spät fertig geworden.
Und jetzt war,
der Fliesenleger, ja,
und kurz darauf,
der Typ, der unten den Boden irgendwie ausgleichen sollte von der Höhe.
So.
Und,
zum Glück war das nicht in allen Räumen und so.
Aber,
es gibt ja von mir auch Videos von der Baustelle noch.
Glücklicherweise wurde das Haus ja nicht neu gebaut,
sondern wirklich nur ganz recht gründlich renoviert.
Zumindest,
wir mussten dann im Bad,
die Wände trocknen.
Und,
ich hab da so einen, so einen großen, also,
ich hab da so einen großen Lüfter reingestellt zum Pusten.
Noch mehr Lüfter reingestellt zum Pusten.
Ich hab alles, was wir, was wir haben, mitgebracht.
Von Föns,
bis, ähm, Heißluftgebläse und alles.
Und,
ja, wir hatten, wir hatten so ein, so ein, so ein großes,
so ein großes Pusteding da drinnen.
Aber das hat, das hat,
es hätte bis Montag nicht fertig getrocknet.
Und da standen wir dann samstags da,
und haben die Wände getrocknet.
Mit allen, mit allem Möglichen, was wir hatten.
Einen halben Tag,
einen halben Tag auf gepustetem,
und da drinnen war es heiß, Alter.
Da war es gefühlt 150 Grad oder so drinnen.
Na, war es nicht, da werden wir abgefackelt.
Aber,
ja, das war so warm.
Ich stand da nur noch in der Unterhose.
Und das war im Winter.
Hi, ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin die Maria.
Moin, Daniel.
Und wir bauen hier südlich von Ulm unser Traumhaus,
zusammen mit unserer Tochter Nora.
Und wir schauen mal, ob sich das Ganze lohnt.
Ulm?
In Ulm?
Oder nicht nahe von Ulm,
war ich öfters mal.
Haben nicht Elo-Tricks besucht, nein.
Da habe ich meine Ausbildung damals gemacht,
in der Nähe von Ulm.
Also, die.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Meine Ausbildung habe ich in Frankfurt gemacht,
aber die Firma, bei der ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
die saß in der Nähe von Ulm.
Und Ulmer Busfahrer ist, glaube ich,
das unfreundlichste, was ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe.
Und ich mag den Schwaben-Dialekt nicht.
Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ich,
war das nicht mega die Fahrerei für dich?
Doch.
Ich musste da glücklicherweise nicht so oft hin.
Ich musste da ein paar Mal im Jahr hin.
Das war schon handelbar.
Nice Thron-Shot.
Traumhaus hier in der Nähe von Ulm.
210 Quadratmeter groß.
Du magst kein Schwäbisch.
Nee, mag ich nicht.
So isch des.
Mag kein Schwäbisch.
Zehn Zimmer.
Drei Bäder.
Die Arbeiten der Baufirma sind fast fertig.
Ja, so Dinger.
Ah, warte, warte, warte.
Die Arbeiten der Baufirma sind fast fertig.
So Ecken haben wir getrocknet.
Das Wochenende über.
Fertig.
Aber Maria und Daniel machen noch richtig viel selbst,
um Geld zu sparen.
Das habe ich halt nicht gemacht.
So viel selbst haben wir nicht gemacht.
Ich habe lieber ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgegeben.
Deswegen hatten wir auch, wie gesagt,
einen Architekt am Start.
Der hat das täglich überwacht und geguckt.
Da war sein Geld auch wirklich wert.
Weil der hat ja auch immer gleich angeschissen,
wenn irgendwas nicht richtig ist.
Weil ansonsten hättest du wieder das Problem gehabt.
Der eine sagt, ah, der, keine Ahnung,
der Verputzer hat es verkackt.
Der Verputzer sagt, nein, nein,
wie hast du da deine Fliesen dran gemacht?
Dann kommt der Typ und schmeißt irgendwie was auf dir.
Er sagt, ah, das ist Schepp.
Das liegt aber nicht an mir.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Und wie viel kostet es normal?
Also ich glaube, das Renovieren bei uns hier im Haus,
das hat knapp 100.000 Euro gekostet.
So, über den Daumen gepeilt.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
So in dem Dreh.
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal, was es gekostet hätte,
wäre das neu gebaut worden.
Wunderbar großen Wohn-Ess-Bereich.
Hier hinten werden wir später mal unser Wohnzimmer aufstellen.
Wir können dann auch hier direkt durch die Glastüre
dann schön raus auf die Terrasse laufen.
Hier hinten, wir werden auch eine Ikea-Küche einbauen.
Jetzt stellt euch mal vor, das ist so ultra teuer
und das Haus ist halb fertig.
Stellt euch mal vor, die stellen morgen fest,
die haben keinen Bock mehr aufeinander.
Und dann?
Dann müssen die es irgendwie versuchen zu verkaufen.
Dann gehen die mit richtig krass Minus raus.
Die Küche ist fertig, reicht so.
Wenn die das jetzt verkaufen,
gehen die mit ordentlich Minus raus.
So ein halbfertiges Haus will doch keiner kaufen, oder?
Sagt doch niemand, dass die mit Minus rausgehen.
Doch, ich sag das.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass sie das dafür bekommen, was sie da reingesteckt haben.
Zumindest sehen wir den Zustand.
Und dann zusammen ungefähr 8.000 Euro,
also inklusive der Elektrogeräte.
Aber gut, letztendlich, wir sind uns alle drüber einig.
Muss jeder selbst wissen.
Und es ist halt ein Risiko,
was man sich überlegen muss.
Ist halt so.
Und dann haben wir hier eine riesenlange Arbeitsplatte.
Die geht dann über die komplette Länge hier rüber.
Wir haben genau exakt unterm Fenster unser Spülbecken.
Die Enden sind das Beste.
Wo wir hoffen, dass das später auch mal aufgehen wird,
weil der Wasserhahn praktisch genau hier in der Mitte hochgucken wird.
Und wenn wir dann das Fenster aufmachen,
dann geht hoffentlich das Fenster einmal am Wasserhahn vorbei.
Wir haben es genau so geplant, wie es jetzt hier dasteht.
Das ist genau unser Gedankengut.
Und das merken wir jedes Mal, wenn wir hier reingehen.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal in den Schlafraum.
Noch sieht man da ja nicht so viel, oder?
Hier war ein Kompromiss.
Doch, die gehen wahrscheinlich durch das Haus
und sehen schon in ihrem Kopf immer, wie es fertig aussieht.
Wir nicht, aber die schon.
Maria wollte unbedingt ein Ankleidezimmer haben.
Ein was?
Was macht man mit einem Ankleidezimmer?
Da hat man dann drei Kleiderschränke stehen und zieht sich an.
Na gut, gar nicht so blöd.
Wenn ich mir so recht überlege, gar nicht so blöd,
wenn man sehr viele Klamotten hat.
Wenn man sehr viele Klamotten hat und morgens tatsächlich guckt,
ziehe ich heute das an, ziehe ich heute das an?
Why not?
Die wissen es am besten, was für sie wichtig ist.
Joch, die Decke, ich glaube, die ist gar nicht so Decke.
Das ist einfach nur ein bisschen schräg hier neben.
Und vielleicht müssen ja noch irgendwelche Kabel und so drunter.
So sieht eigentlich ganz normal hoch aus.
An dieser Wand kommen vollflächig Schränke hin.
Und das hier wird verkleidet mit USB-Platten und mit Rigips.
Da kann man leider nicht mehr durchsehen.
Die guten USB-Platten.
Sowohl links als auch rechts kann man daran vorbeilaufen.
Und vom Schlafzimmer aus kommen wir dann hier direkt ins Badezimmer rein.
Ich nehme mich da noch kurz mit.
Ja, unsere Badewanne ist schon da.
Und warum kostet es jetzt mehr?
Und hier hinten haben wir dann eine riesengroße begehbare Dusche.
Ja, und warum kostet das jetzt mehr?
Auf die Wände 1,20 Meter auf 60 große Fliesen.
Also wann kommt denn jetzt der eigentliche Knackpunkt,
warum das mehr kostet?
Aus den ersten YouTube-Videos, die ich mir angeschaut habe,
sollte es funktionieren, 1,20 Meter auf 60 Fliesen an die Wand zu kleben.
Aber wir lassen das jetzt so.
Aber wir lassen uns mal überraschen.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal runter.
Mein Verdienst ist gerade eben, 70 Prozent arbeite ich im Moment.
Elternzeit bis Nora drei Jahre alt ist, bekomme ich im Moment 2.600 netto raus.
Und theoretischerweise wären es drei, aber ich zahle noch 400 Euro für meinen Firmenwagen,
der dann natürlich andere Vorteile mit sich bringt.
Bei mir ist es so, ich arbeite gerade auch Teilzeit in Elternzeit.
Und da verdiene ich 1.200 netto circa.
Also wir verdienen im Endeffekt gemeinsam zusammen im Monat 4.500 Euro netto.
Inklusive Kindergeld, bayerisches Familiengeld und so weiter.
Also wir haben 4.500 Euro netto im Monat zur Verfügung.
Genau.
Und wenn euch interessiert...
Und wie jetzt?
Und warum kostet das jetzt mehr?
Warum haben wir das geguckt?
Ich fühle mich gebetet.
Was ist hier los?
Gebetet.
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwie noch was.
Warum das so viel teurer geworden ist?
War das einfach nur eine Cross-Promotion für die ARD-Mediathek oder was?
Alter.
Dazu fällt mir jetzt ja echt nur noch ein...
Wir gehen jetzt sicherlich nicht in die ARD-Mediathek.
Liest ihr die Videobeschreibung durch?
Nö.
Lese ich mir nichts mehr durch hier.
Die habe ich gebetet.
Da wird nichts durch gelesen.
Steht da drin.
Ja klar, weil auch jeder immer zuerst die Videobeschreibung liest.
Ne?
Ihr lest immer die Videobeschreibung, bevor ihr ein Video guckt.
Wer macht's nicht?
Ja.
Natürlich macht ihr das alle.
Obviously.
Lohnen sich teure elektrische Zahnbürsten?
Ich benutze ab und zu eine.
So teuer ist die aber nicht.
Weil man ganz hinten...
Oftmals nur hinten...
Ganz oben links hinter den Zahn,
sonst mit normalen Zahnbürsten nicht gescheit hinkommt.
Du putzt nur ab und zu mit elektrischer Zahnbürste.
Ich benutze das nicht jedes Mal.
Ich benutze die nur dafür, ja.
Ich benutze die nur manchmal für ganz oben links hinten.
Hast du schon mal ein Bart-KI probiert?
Ne.
Was ich jetzt habe, was super praktisch ist...
Interdentalbürsten.
Die benutze ich seit jetzt ungefähr, was weiß ich, einem halben Jahr oder so.
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Du kommst viel besser rein, als mit der normalen Zahnbürste.
Ja.
Ich habe mir da erst so ein paar Packen gekauft seit einem halben Jahr.
Und das also ursprünglich war ja, weil der Zahnarzt meinte, es wäre ein bisschen entzündet.
Das liegt nicht am Zahn, das wäre entzündet.
Und dann habe ich angefangen, damit die Zwischenräume zu putzen oben links.
Weil man da...
Was macht man damit?
Man schiebt das zwischen die Zähne unten.
Unten, wo ein bisschen Platz zwischen den Zähnen ist.
Je nachdem braucht man...
Die gibt es ja auch bis zu 0,2 Millimeter Größe.
Und seitdem...
Es hat am Anfang übelst weh getan beim Putzen und nach dem Putzen, weil es halt entzündet war zwischen den Zähnen.
Und seitdem ich das jetzt aber regelmäßig mache...
Ist komplett weg.
Es blutet nicht mehr.
Es tut nicht mehr weh.
Und dementsprechend kann ich das wirklich empfehlen.
Also wenn ihr irgendwie ein bisschen Probleme Zahnfleisch-mäßig habt...
Und es euch irgendwie weh tut...
Anzähnen, Zwischenzähnen und es nicht die Zähne selbst sind...
Nehmt diese Bürsten.
Zu gucken, welche euch da gut gefallen.
Kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Ist top.
Hast du schon einmal versucht...
Okay.
Diese IP-Adresse hier anzupingen.
Warum erhält man dann eine Antwort vom Localhost?
Handelt es sich bei diesen beiden IP-Adressen etwa um dieselbe?
Wir lassen uns das jetzt erklären.
Also streng genommen ist 0.0.0.0 gar keine gültige IP-Adresse.
IP-Adresse 127.0.0.1 ist eine spezielle Adresse, die auf jedem Computer als Loopback-Adresse definiert ist.
Diese Adresse wird oft auch als Localhost bezeichnet, was bedeutet, dass ihr auf den aktuellen...
Da hat er recht.
Aber ich zeige euch mal was.
Weiß nicht, ob er da drauf eingeht.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ping 127.0.0.2.
Leute, was passiert jetzt?
Also hier sind wir uns ja einig.
So, was passiert jetzt?
127.0.0.2.
Was passiert da jetzt?
Siehe da, es funktioniert.
Und was meint ihr, was bei 3 ist?
Es funktioniert auch.
Und was meint ihr, was bei 69 ist?
Das funktioniert auch.
MonkaS.
Und jetzt kommt die Preisfrage, Chatge.
Was passiert hier?
420, das ist keine gültige IP.
Es geht auch.
MonkaS.
Werde das gedacht.
Und was passiert hier?
Es geht auch.
Also man erkennt, glaube ich, das System so langsam.
Aber jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert hier?
Das funktioniert nicht.
Zumindest unter Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es unter Windows auch so ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, unter Windows ist es auch so.
Dieser gesamte Adressbereich, das gesamte 127.0.8 ist es quasi.
Das ist gemappt auf Localhost.
... Computer verweist, auf dem man sich gerade befindet, unabhängig von der tatsächlichen Netzwerkverbindung.
Wenn ein Computer die Adresse 127.0.0.1 verwendet, kommuniziert er also mit sich selbst über das lokale Netzwerkinterface.
Damit ist auch klar, was dieses Meme hier bedeutet.
There is no place like 127.0.0.1.
Normalerweise heißt es ja, there is no place like home.
Und im Prinzip stellt 127.0.0.1 die Heimatadresse auf dem eigenen Computer dar.
Daher, there is no place like localhost.
Wenn wir beispielsweise einen XAMPP-Server...
Oder wisst ihr, was richtig cringe ist?
Die Leute, die anstatt Localhost, Localhorn haben.
Das sind die gleichen, die nicht Windows, sondern Winddoof sagen.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Ich finde das immer richtig...
... richtig Dice of Cringe.
Finde ich das.
... aber lokal auf unserem Rechner starten.
Das habe ich ja schon 20 Jahre in der Mac gesehen, ey.
Winzig, weich, winddoof.
Ja, das ist auch... oh, das ist so cringe, Alter.
... und die URL-Leiste 127.0.0.1.
Oder auch einfach nur Localhost anbieten.
Von wann ist das Video von vor 10 Tagen?
Dann werden wir auf die Default-Page des Servers auf unserem eigenen...
Sofern der an Loopback lauscht, dann geht das.
... Computer-Adresse geleitet.
Dass du also den Localhost nicht pingen kannst, ist demnach nicht möglich.
Denn du solltest dich schließlich immer selbst erreichen können.
127.0.0.1 ist nicht die IP-Adresse, über die andere Computer einen selbst im lokalen Netzwerk ansprechen können.
Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise von einem anderen Computer diese Seite hier aufrufen möchte,
dann muss ich zuerst mit ifconfig oder ipconfig, wenn ich mich auf einem Windows-Rechner befinde,
die IP-Adresse im Netzwerk herausfinden und diese dann von dem anderen Rechner aus...
Wobei die coolen Leute, die coolen Leute ja heute auch nicht ifconfig, sondern ipadd verwenden.
Warum? Weil es cooler ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht warum.
Nur dass das ifconfig halt oftmals nicht defaultmäßig mitkommt mehr.
Früher war es immer ifconfig.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die noch cooleren nehmen ipa, ja.
Oder noch cooleren nehmen ipaddre.
Geht auch ipaddre? Ja, geht auch.
Die Ausgabe ist ein bisschen kompakter.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich persönlich bin ja ein ifconfig-User.
Also ich benutze eigentlich lieber ifconfig.
Ich kann euch weder sagen warum, vielleicht weil ich die Ausgaben ein bisschen übersichtlicher finde.
Seid ihr ifconfig-Enjoyer oder eher ipcommand-User?
ifconfig.
Ich weiß, dass es deprecated ist, aber ich benutze trotzdem lieber ipadd.
0.0.0.0 ist hingegen eine nicht rootbare IPv4-Adresse, die eine andere Bedeutung hat.
Die eigentlich, ich glaube, gar keine richtig gültige IP ist.
Also zumindest unter Windows, glaube ich, geht das nicht.
Unter Linux glaube ich, dass es funktioniert.
Ja.
Das ist irgendwie da gealiast auf localhost, keine Ahnung.
Das sind aber sowieso Feinheiten, ja.
Sie wird als unbestimmte oder beliebige Adresse verwendet.
Wenn ein Server auf die Adresse 0.0.0.0 eintritt...
Man benutzt das beispielsweise gerne bei Firewall-Regeln,
um any zu symbolisieren.
Um any zu symbolisieren.
Ja.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, es ist erlaubt von any,
dann ist es oftmals 0.0.0.0 slash 0.
Bedeutet das...
Als Filtermaske.
Dass er auf allen verfügbaren Netzwerkinterfaces lauscht
und auf eingehende Verbindungen von allen IP-Adressen auf dem Host wartet.
Oder für Interface-Binding, ja.
Binding bedeutet im Allgemeinen, dass der Server sich auf eine bestimmte Netzwerkadresse
und einen Port festlegt.
Das heißt...
Im Prinzip von wo er Verbindungen annimmt.
Also auf was er Verbindungen annimmt.
...sagt dem Betriebssystem, auf welche IPv4-Adresse und auf welchen Port er auf eingehende Netzwerkverbindungen
warten soll.
Das wird zum Beispiel genutzt, um in Python einen Server zu programmieren.
Wenn du beispielsweise mit dem Befehl python-m...
Es ist kein Global Broadcast.
Wenn du Broadcast haben willst, das ist meistens dann sowas wie 255.
Allerdings passend zum Netz.
Es muss nicht zwangsläufig 255 sein.
...HTTP-Server, ein bereits vorgefertigtes Skript zur schnellen Bereitstellung eines Servers startest,
dann wird dir die Meldung, serving HTTP on 0.0.0.0...
Und jetzt Netznetz hinterher...
Ups, sorry.
Ich wollte gar nicht gerade so laut klatschen.
Wenn jetzt Netznetz hinterher haust, siehst du es auch.
Python bindet also nicht auf die Localhost-Adresse,
127.0.0.1, sondern auf die unbestimmte Adresse 0.0.0.0.
Das ist auch notwendig, denn wenn du den Server selbst über einen Socket programmierst
und als Adresse 127.0.0.1 einträgst,
wird dir bei dem Verbindungsversuch über einen Python-Client von einem anderen Computer aus
die Meldung Connection Refused angezeigt, weil wir...
Man könnte doch einfach curl benutzen.
Aber das ist natürlich nichts für echte Python-Hacker mehr.
...wir uns nicht nur lokal auf dem Rechner befinden, auf dem auch der Server läuft.
0.0.0.0 wird oft in Server-Konfigurationen verwendet,
wenn der Server auf allen Netzwerkinterfaces des Hosts verfügbar sein soll.
Außerdem kann es dabei helfen, den Server von Clients auf verschiedene Netzwerkadressen erreichbar zu machen.
In Kombination mit einem Port, zum Beispiel 1337, gibt die IP-Adresse an...
Das ist eh der beste Port.
...auf welchen Netzwerkinterface und Port der Server auf eingehende Verbindungen wartet.
Ob man dafür nun 127.0.0.1 oder 0.0.0.0 nutzt, hängt von den Anforderungen des Servers ab.
Wenn der Server nur auf dem selben Computer lokal erreichbar sein soll, verwendet man 127.0.0.1, also den Local Host.
Wenn der Server von anderen Geräten im lokalen Netzwerk aus erreichbar sein soll...
Ich gehe davon aus, den meisten war das klar, aber ich finde, er erklärt das immer gut.
...verwendet man entweder die IP-Adresse des lokalen Netzwerks...
...oder die IP-Adresse des lokalen Netzwerkinterfaces, also zum Beispiel die 192.168.56.1, also die IP-Adresse, die der Rechner im Netzwerk hat...
...oder 0.0.0.0, um auf allen Netzwerkinterfaces zu lauschen.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Oh, 23 Minuten, das geht nicht, ich habe Hunger, ich muss was essen.
Alle Karriere... Moment, 60 Minuten, the fuck?
Oh, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Das ist mir zu lang.
Videospiele cracken, illegal, aber moralisch vertretbar.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Haben wir irgendwas?
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Das ist von Hermes, das ist Werbung für eine Ausbildung bei Hermes.
Da wollte ich ja mal bei Gelegenheit reingucken, was Hermes so zu bieten hat.
Gibt es Lachs mit Nudeln? Ja... Ne, nein, nein, es gibt heute nicht Lachs mit Nudeln.
Heute gibt es nicht Lachs mit Nudeln.
Ratet mal, was es heute gibt. Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Ich meine, es gibt bei mir Samstag immer zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Es gibt entweder Lachs mit Nudeln oder Lachs mit...
Nein, nein, nein, es gibt heute kein Lachs mit Nudeln.
Es gibt zwei Sachen bei mir Samstags immer.
Es gibt entweder Lachs mit Nudeln oder es gibt Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Und es ist Sonntag, ja das stimmt.
Aber das Essen ist immer noch von Samstag übrig.
Deswegen esse ich das heute.
Also bei mir gibt es Samstags entweder Nudeln mit Lachs...
...oder Nudeln mit Tomatensauce und ordentlich Parmesan-Kes drüber.
Und den Rest futter ich dann Sonntag noch.
So sieht's aus.
Was Kleines können wir noch gucken.
Gucken wir uns das an.
Videospiele cracken. Illegal aber moralisch vertretbar.
Naja...
Gucken was er dazu sagt.
Lass die Finger von Opera.
Echt, warum?
Warum? Weil China-Chinesen-Browser.
Das sag ich die ganze Zeit schon.
schon. Seit
Opera zu den China-Chinesen gehört,
will ich davon nichts mehr wissen. Aber warum?
Warum? Was sagt er?
Influencer werben aktuell für den
Browser Opera und dessen
Gamer-Version Opera G. Was zum Teufel
ist im Hintergrund los?
Die Musik, oder?
The thing I spent a long time using recently
is the Opera Desktop Browser.
Mit denen wollte ich auch schon mal Werbung machen.
Wisst ihr, warum das nicht geklappt hat?
Eigentlich spricht
das sogar
für die, warum das nicht geklappt hat.
Die wollten, dass ich Werbung machen für ihren
RGB Gaming Browser. Also
Opera GX war das dann.
Und wir waren uns da auch schon so mehr oder
weniger einig. Und
es scheiterte daran,
dass ich gefragt habe,
okay, also
muss ich das Produkt wirklich
für das Video benutzen und muss ich das wirklich
gut finden? Ich habe
keine Probleme damit, was zu bewerben,
wenn es klar ist, dass es Werbung ist.
Auch wenn ich das nicht gut finde.
Also
wollt ihr, dass ich sage
in dem Video, dass ich das persönlich
empfehle und dass
ich das gut finde?
Dann haben die halt gesagt, ja, das wollen sie.
Da habe ich ihnen halt zurückgeschrieben, ja, aber
ich halte von eurem Browser nichts.
Ich mag euren Browser aber nicht.
Und
daraufhin haben die dann gesagt, na gut, dann machen wir
lieber kein Placement.
Eigentlich lustig,
oder?
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige, der
das so gesagt hat.
Das spricht aber eigentlich echt
für die, ja.
Spricht eigentlich, ich finde aber auch, es spricht
ein bisschen für mich, auch
weil ich nichts als, ich empfehle
es verkaufen wollte, was ich
nicht mag, ja.
Spricht tatsächlich für beide.
Okay.
Wuppidiwupp, wupp, wupp.
Shout out an Opera GX.
So, download the upgrade,
the updated version of the Opera Browser.
Und Freunde, ich nutze seitdem kein...
Alter, was hat der Typ für einen komischen Kompressor
da am Start?
Einen anderen mehr.
Unmenschlich cool und modern.
Dass sich andere Browser anfühlen...
...fühlen wie aus der
Windows XP Zeit.
Seit wann gehört das den Chinesen?
Oh, schon lange.
Lange. Ich glaube,
das bestimmt, bestimmt, ich weiß nicht, ob es
10 Jahre ist oder so.
Die haben das schon lange gekauft.
...browser for anyone remotely interested in tech.
In meiner Kommentarspalte, als ich
vor dem neuen Update von Google Chrome
gewarnt habe, war Opera GX
der mit Abstand meist
genannte Browser, den ihr benutzt,
um sicher vor der
Datenkrake Google zu sein.
Sogar im Stream letzte Woche wurde ich
darauf angesprochen, was ich zu diesem Browser
meine. Und ja, ich habe
auch schon einige Sponsoring-Angebote
vorliegen gehabt von Opera GX.
Und nein...
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, warum es bei ihm nicht geklappt hat.
...warum der Browser nicht nur ein bisschen problematisch,
sondern richtig gefährlich werden kann,
das erfahrt ihr hier.
Und ja, es wird schlimmer, je tiefer man
reingeht. Und genau das tun wir heute.
Ich versuche hier übrigens nicht ganz so
technisch zu werden und euch nur die
Ergebnisse der durchaus langen
Recherche zu präsentieren.
Okay.
Da solche Recherchen...
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was da jetzt kommt.
Ich habe immer einen großen Bogen,
um Opera gemacht, seit es China-Chinesen-Zeug
ist. Wenn jemand
einen Browser benutzen will,
der ein bisschen ist wie der alte Opera,
der kann Vivaldi benutzen,
weil Vivaldi-Browser
ist von dem ehemaligen Opera-Erfinder.
Wenn ich nach Vivaldi suche,
ist natürlich blöd, weil
Komponist und Browser und so.
Also ihr erkennt auch schon den Zusammenhang
an der Stelle.
Erfinder. Ja.
Ja.
Von dem gleichen Typ.
Oder von den gleichen Typen.
Zumindest von dem gleichen Typ.
Ob Brave Browser empfehlenswert ist, keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe eh nicht, warum man was anderes
verwendet als Firefox und Chrome.
Die ganz edgy Leute,
die sagen, ich will das nicht.
Die können auch Edge verwenden.
Aber warum sollte ich irgendwas anderes
außer Firefox und Chrome verwenden?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Euch steht mir nicht ein.
... Experimente allerdings immer viel
Zeit benötigen, danke ich heute
unserem Sponsor...
Oder der Haube ist es ja auch.
Außerdem auch noch überall Chrome, ja.
... Video.
Datenbroker, die weltweit Daten verkaufen,
sind ein riesiges Problem,
das wir auch noch in diesem Video
weiter besprechen werden.
Diese Daten werden zwar oft legal erworben...
Ach, das ist Werbung.
... ... löschen sollen.
Dazu habt ihr das Recht.
Klar, es gibt wahnsinnig viele solcher Broker
und es ist sehr viel Arbeit,
sie alle anzuschreiben, aber
... 60% Rabatt mit meinem Code.
Zurück zu
Opera und Opera GX.
Sie positionieren sich ganz klar aktuell
als die coolen Browser,
die Browser für Gen Z, für echte
Gamer. RGB Gaming.
Das sieht man vor allem an ihrem Twitter.
Sorry, X-Account.
Frisst 80% weniger RAM.
Ihr könnt sogar die Hardware-Ressourcen
limitieren, Designs anpassen
und ihr habt RAM.
Ihr könnt sogar die
Hardware-Ressourcen limitieren,
Designs anpassen und ihr habt
direkt Twitch und Discord in der
Seitenleiste. Dann noch ein Gaming-Release-Kalender,
integrierter App-Blocker und...
... Niemand braucht das.
Ich verstehe nicht, was das...
Also, wozu?
Also, ich meine, Discord.
Tab. Okay, ja, weil
meinetwegen. Das Einzige... Also, ich hab mir das
natürlich auch mal angeguckt, das Ding.
Das Einzige, was ich irgendwie ganz nett
fand, ist tatsächlich, dass du
irgendwie
unterschiedliche Themes hast,
aber eingebaut. Aber das hast du für alle anderen
Browser... Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung.
... deine Geheimnisse
sicher mit einer kostenlosen
VPN. Erstmal,
eine VPN?
Die VPN? VPN
steht für Virtual Private Network.
Ja, gut. Das... Da würde ich
bei den China-Chinesen nicht so genau
drauf achten, dass sie das ordentlich übersetzen.
Er hat recht, aber da würde ich jetzt mir nicht
so viel Gedanken drum machen. Netzwerk. Aber auch
der normale Opera ohne GX
wirbt speziell
mit Privatsphäre.
Gleichzeitig wird KI in Form eines
Chatbots integriert und sogar auf
Web3, also Krypto, NFT
und Co. gesetzt.
Spätestens ab dem Punkt wäre ich raus,
Alter. Endlich Fortschritt.
Und das alles gratis für uns.
Und so viel kann ich sagen, es sind nicht die
Features, die das Problem sind. Zumindest
nicht, welche Features es sind.
Das Problem fängt viel
tiefer an. Dazu muss man aber immer verstehen,
woher kommt eigentlich
das Geld? Also, wer finanziert diesen
Browser, der uns alle... China-Chinesen.
Wenn wir Endkunden
ihn eigentlich sogar gratis bekommen.
Opera verdient
Geld mit Ads. Das ist erstmal
recht einfach zu sehen. Als Firma
kann ich nämlich in einem Ad-Manager Werbung
für meine Dienste schalten. Die meisten User
sind laut Opera zwischen...
Sind die nett und selbstlos, uns das
verwenden zu lassen. ...und 24
Jahren alt. Die zweitmeisten 25
bis 34. Gen Z und
Gamer eben. Wie gesagt.
Die Werbung ist in 25 bis 34.
Bei mir ist... Ich bin schon...
Ich bin schon nicht mehr dabei.
Gen Z und Gamer eben. Wie gesagt.
Die Werbung ist im Browser
oder dem Newsfeed integriert. Und
was braucht man für Ads? Richtig.
Daten. Und mit einem Browser
ist das am einfachsten
von allem. Welche Informationen hat
denn so ein Browser? Naja, fangen
wir vorne mit dem technischen Experiment
an. Wenn ich den Browser starte,
ohne, dass ich irgendetwas selbst
tue, verbindet sich der
Browser mit opera.com.
Das ist auf der einen Seite natürlich logisch,
und nötig, damit der Browser prüfen kann, ob es
zum Beispiel Updates gibt. Gleichzeitig
liefert es aber Opera auch
meine IP-Adresse, die genutzt wird,
um die Sprache zum Beispiel für Websites
zu ermitteln. Diese IP-Adresse reicht aber
aus damit. Das ist jetzt... Also
das würde ich jetzt an der Stelle nicht mal so
wild sehen. Das macht wahrscheinlich
so gut wie
nahezu alles mit einem
eingebauten Updater.
Also insofern.
Deswegen sind Package-Manager ja auch nice.
Da muss nicht jedes Programm seinen eigenen Updater mitbringen.
Also das würde ich
jetzt noch nicht mal so kritisch sehen an der Stelle.
Opera von euch einen
ziemlich genauen Standort hat.
Dazu liefert Opera euch jetzt aber
auch noch eine UUID,
also eine unter allen
Opera-Nutzern eindeutige
Kennung, die nur in
eurer Installation hinterlegt ist.
Damit kann Opera, auch
wenn ihr beispielsweise das Smartphone mit nach
Australien nehmt, eindeutig erkennen,
dass immer noch ihr das seid
und nicht irgendjemand anders. Die Opera-Server
liefern danach noch eurem Browser einige
Werbepartner wie Amazon oder
Booking.com. Das sind die,
die ihr am Ende auf der Startseite nach
der Installation sehen könnt.
Außerdem wird übermittelt, woher
ihr den Browser habt, also zum Beispiel
über eine Suchmaschine gefunden und die
Website von Opera wird euch angezeigt.
Bis jetzt soweit noch
Standard leider für viele
Sachen heutzutage. Anschließend
wird nach euren Add-ons geschaut und die
werden auf Updates überprüft.
Und wer jetzt sicher sein will vor der
Datenkrake Google,
den muss ich hier enttäuschen.
Der schickt es halt zu den
China-Chinesen. Kannst dir aussuchen,
wem du den Kram gibst. Google immer
kontaktiert. Also wirklich immer.
Wenn ihr jetzt anfangt,
diesen Browser zu benutzen, also eine
Website aufruft, wird automatisch
jede einzelne
aufgerufene Website an
Opera geschickt. Also jede.
Das ist erstmal eine
Sicherheitsfunktion, bei der Opera
bei sich auf dem Server prüft,
ob diese Seite eine
bekannte Phishing, also eine...
Ja, das macht Google ja auch. Wobei ich nicht
weiß, ob Google es bei jeder Seite macht
oder ob die das irgendwie runterladen und
dann Hashes abgleichen oder sowas.
Bösartige Seite ist. Aber genau
dadurch kann Opera natürlich auch
jede einzelne Website mitschreiben,
die ihr besucht. Aber
zu Operas Verteidigung, es wird nur
der Domain-Namen übermittelt. Also bei diesem
YouTube-Video wird beispielsweise nicht
watch?v?id
übermittelt, sondern nur YouTube.
.com. Dadurch weiß Opera
nicht, welches Video ihr gesehen habt, sondern
nur, dass ihr auf YouTube wart. Diese
Funktion ist übrigens natürlich
nur ein Vorwand für die Firmen, euren
Browserverlauf klauen zu können. Möchte
man es richtig und datenschutzfreundlich
machen, könnte man es auch so machen.
Opera sendet euch einfach
die Blogliste alle halbe Stunde an euer
Gerät, anstatt einfach den gesamten
Verlauf an Opera zu senden.
Dennoch, ihr könnt die Funktion deaktivieren
in den Einstellungen unter
Schütze mich vor bösartigen...
Websites. So wie das zum Beispiel
auch, äh, uBlog macht.
Äh, uBlog.
Auf die Funktion
sollte man sich übrigens eh nicht verlassen.
Diese Blogliste funktionieren in meiner Erfahrung immer
erst eine Woche ungefähr zu spät.
Und hier übrigens ein Funfact,
der sogar belegt, was ich gerade gesagt hab.
Selbst wenn ich diese
Funktion bei Opera deaktiviere, wird
weiterhin jede einzelne
Domain, die man besucht,
an Opera gesendet. Auch wenn die
Funktion aus ist. Und selbst
wenn ich den Inkognito-Modus
aktiviere, ihr wisst schon, der, der für
inkognito, extra private Aktivitäten
gedacht ist, wird jede Domain
an Opera übermittelt.
Ja, das ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Das hab ich ja schon mal vor Urzeiten auch mal
in einem Video bei mir gehabt, weil
damals zumindest und wahrscheinlich leider heute
immer noch viel zu viele Leute immer noch
denken, dass der Inkognito-Modus im Browser
dich irgendwie anonym macht.
Wellenlänge mit
Googles Chrome.
Schütze deine Privatsphäre.
Ich konnte damit übrigens
die Ergebnisse vom Kuketz-Blog nochmal
verifizieren. Aber hey, für
eure Privatsphäre gibt's ja zum Glück
noch diesen VPN, der gratis
dabei ist, richtig?
Opera VPN ist
technisch gesehen kein VPN,
sondern nur ein Browser-Proxy.
Nur die Anfragen aus dem Browser
werden durch den Server geschoben. Nichts
anderes. Das ist zwar erstmal kein Problem,
ist aber irreführendes
Marketing, weil es so einfach falsch
ist. Zu diesen ganzen
möglichen Statements werden wir noch ein paar Mal
kommen. Dazu hat die Quelle,
die ich euch unten verlinke, festgestellt,
dass zwar OpenVPN und WireGuard auf der
Website beschrieben wird, also
Technologien für VPNs, aber im Grunde
wird nur HTTPS
over TLS genutzt. Also
nicht die gängigen Technologien,
die VPNs schnell und sicher machen.
Und der VPN wiederum
macht nichts anderes, als eure
Browser-Anfrage an Opera zu
schicken und von dort dann an
die...
Äh, by the way, dadurch,
dass die werben mit Werbeblocker
und sowas, nur über dieses
VPN, bedeutet
auch, dass die jede
Webseite lesen können
von dir. Was echt
fragwürdig ist, weil sonst könnten
sie keine Werbung blocken.
Was sehr fragwürdig ist und was
normalerweise auch
nicht funktioniert,
es sei denn, du trustest
explizit dem Opera-Zertifikat,
was normale Browser nicht machen, aber
Opera wahrscheinlich schon,
ist SSL von OpenVPN und besser als
SSL von HTTPS. OpenVPN
macht kein SSL.
OpenVPN ist
auf einer ganz anderen
Schicht unterwegs.
Im Osi-Modell!
OpenVPN ist,
das baust du auf,
nicht auf HTTP-Ebene auf,
sondern eins weiter drunter.
OpenVPN ist quasi
TCP-Verbindung
und darüber
du bekommst deine eigene IP
und bekommst quasi ein eigenes Netz,
du musst eine Route setzen
und dann geht dein Traffic da drüber,
verschlüsselt und
SSL ist halt nur
HTTP.
Ja gut, es kann sein, dass die
dass die
dass die OpenSSL
für die Encryption-Version
verwenden.
Das mag sein.
Ich meine im Prinzip ist
ist TLS, also ist HTTP,
TLS selbst, ja auch nicht
auf HTTP-Ebene, sondern auch
eins unten drunter.
Das kann man ja auch sehen, wenn man sich das
mit Wireshark anguckt.
Stimmt, du hast sogar recht, standardmäßig ist es sogar UDP.
Das stimmt schon,
TLS ist auch eins unten drunter,
weil das ist ja nicht,
also du kannst ja kein HTTP
machen darüber,
wenn es auf HTTP aufsetzt.
Wisst ihr, das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Das ist auch eins unten drunter.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum du normalerweise,
kein HTTPS
über einen Proxy gescheit machen kannst.
Sobald HTTPS
über einen Proxy geht, gibt es nur zwei
Varianten. Entweder
unterstützt der Proxy, ich glaube Connect
heißt das. Das ist mehr oder weniger
Layer 4 Weiterleitung von
TLS Sessions.
Oder
du vertraust dem Proxy
Zertifikaten, der kann reingucken.
Was du normalerweise nicht machen willst.
Kannst du mal den Unterschied der oberen zwei schicken?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Obere zwei Schichten, Presentation und Session?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das ist eh alles ein bisschen
pepega und oldschool, diese ganze
Osi-Modell-Geschichte.
Aber der Unterschied ist, dass du
OpenVPN,
es stimmt übrigens auch gar nicht, was ich
erzählt habe, also
OpenVPN geht ganz normal
IP-mäßig übers Internet,
baut eine Verbindung auf mit dem OpenVPN-Server,
allerdings dann bekommst du
eine extra, eine eigene Netzwerkkarte,
eine virtuelle Netzwerkkarte raus am Ende,
ein, wie heißt das,
Tun-Device,
Tab ist noch ein so drunter, wo du
kompletten IP-Layer-3-Traffic
drüber tunneln kannst.
Also sprich, du kriegst eine eigene IP aus dem Netz
und kannst tatsächlich mit den Endpunkten auf der
anderen Seite reden.
Übers Internet geht das natürlich selbstverständlich
public über
den schon bestehenden Weg,
weil irgendwie musst du ja zum Ziel kommen.
Und da drin ist dann aber alles verschlüsselt.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel,
über einen
OpenVPN-Tunnel
könntest du beispielsweise
irgendwelche
alten Games
spielen,
die
kein TCP unterstützen.
So, sagen wir mal so IPX oder irgendwie sowas.
Könntest du theoretisch machen.
Und du kannst sogar
noch weiter gehen, du kannst
anstatt so einen Tunnel, kannst du ein
Tab-Device machen, das ist ein Layer-2-OpenVPN.
Dann kannst du sogar
Broadcasts über deinen VPN schicken.
Dann geht dann sogar so Sachen wie
Auto-Discovery von
von der Konsole oder
sowas. Kannst du dann zwei
Playstation 2 anschließen
und die sehen sich dann.
Solche Sachen.
Das ist nochmal eine ganze Ecke, eine ganze Ebene tiefer,
als wenn du irgendwie einen Proxy
im Browser einträgst.
Guck mal weiter.
Wo sind wir denn eigentlich?
Die Website.
Also, auch durch die VPN-Funktion
bekommt OperaVision
euren vollständigen Browser-Verlauf
und sogar die Webseite, die ihr besucht.
Also ja, gegenüber
anderen Anbietern seid ihr durch den VPN
vielleicht ein bisschen geschützt,
aber halt auch nur bedingt.
Denn OperaSales...
Ja, auch nicht wirklich. Das ist ja auch das, was ich immer
bei VPN-Anbietern kritisiere,
die groß da was von Privatsphäre
schreiben oder so. Eigentlich hast du
nicht großartig was dadurch gewonnen,
weil
dein Request muss ja immer noch
zum eigentlichen Ziel.
Das heißt, normalerweise
geht das so.
Ihr macht Google auf.
Dann geht das zu eurem Router.
Euer Router geht raus über euer, keine Ahnung,
DSL-Modem. Das geht dann zu Vodafone.
Dann wird das weiter. Irgendwo kommt das
dann wahrscheinlich im D6 in Frankfurt raus
bei irgendeinem Google-Server
oder wo auch immer Google steht in Frankfurt.
Dann kannst du,
bekommst du die Antwort zurück.
Das geht dann public übers Internet.
Eure Packages.
Google kann natürlich lesen,
was in eurer Anfrage drinsteht, weil
Google muss ja die Anfrage liefern.
Also zumindest Google kann lesen, was ihr
anfragt. Das ist klar.
Und das Einzige, was jetzt passiert ist,
es wird der Weg verschlüsselt
von euch, also wenn du über, sagen wir mal
ein VPN. Du gehst über ein VPN.
Der Weg zwischen
euch und dem VPN-Server
ist verschlüsselt.
Aber danach nichts mehr.
Und der Rückweg zurück zum VPN-Server
ist genauso wenig oder genauso
viel verschlüsselt wie ohne.
Und nachdem
eh heutzutage
99% aller Webseiten über HTTPS
gehen, ist das
kein allzu großer Unterschied
beim normalen Surfen.
Ja, ein bisschen
mehr, aber letztendlich
die interessanten,
beteiligten Parteien
können, also wenn
irgendjemand, also Google wird
sich dafür interessieren für den Traffic.
Die müssen den aber auch lesen können,
damit sie euch überhaupt eine Antwort
drauf schicken können.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
ah, aber, fragt mich nicht, die
China-Chinesen und die Amis und der
BND und was auch immer, können
dann aber meinen Traffic nicht angucken,
muss man sich erstmal fragen, okay, was
treibt ihr so?
Aber selbst das hilft ja nicht,
weil nach dem Exit
vom VPN-Netzwerk
geht der Traffic ganz
normal durchs Internet zum Zielserver.
Und
zufällig,
drück auch.
Also wirklich großartig
schützen vor irgendwas,
tut euch ein VPN nicht.
VPN ist
vielleicht sinnvoll, wenn man
eine IP braucht aus
den USA für
Netflix oder so.
Oder wenn man live streamt
und seine IP
daheim nicht leaken möchte oder so was.
Aus Versehen.
Da mag das alles irgendwie sinnvoll
sein, aber für Anonymisierungszwecke
eigentlich nicht.
Und
ja, könnte man jetzt sagen,
okay,
es wird dann oft angeführt, ja, aber die
Anbieter können euch dann nicht mehr IP
tracken. Nun gut,
naja, doch können
sie schon, weil ihr habt ja zumindest für die
Session die gleiche
Absender-IP vom VPN,
die ändert sich ja nicht.
Und ihr loggt euch ja oftmals auch ein
bei den
Diensten oder habt schon gesetzte Cookies.
Oder habt schon gesetzte Cookies.
Daran können die euch ja easy, ohne irgendwelche Fingerprints oder sonst was erkennen, ganz ohne Probleme.
Also, ob ihr heute von einer Vodafone-IP kommt und morgen von einer chinakinesen VPN-IP.
Das ist dem Anbieter vollkommen egal.
Und da müssen wir noch gar nicht in Richtung Browser-Fingerprinting gehen.
So mit Emojis und Grafikkarten malen und gucken, wie's aussieht.
Und was es da nicht alles für krasse Tricks mittlerweile gibt.
Also, nur um das kurz auszuführen.
Also eine beliebte Fingerprint-Technik, äh Technologie ist falsch, eine beliebte Browser-Fingerprint-Technik, also mit Browser-Fingerprint ist gemeint, dass du einem Browser, einem Benutzer zuordnen kannst. Relativ eindeutig.
Früher hat man das zum Beispiel so gemacht mit installierten Schriftarten, da hat man so eine Kombination genommen aus User-Agent und installierte Schriftarten und alles mögliche, was man so gefunden hat und das in Kombination war dann relativ eindeutig für einen Rechner bzw. eine Browser-Installation, halt dementsprechend einen User im Endeffekt.
Mittlerweile sind Browser da schon ein bisschen besser, Browser geben nicht mehr die installierten Schriftarten raus, User-Agents gibt es heutzutage ja auch nicht mehr, in dem Sinn ist alles der gleiche.
Oder meistens.
Meistens der gleiche User-Agent überall, das heißt es ist, ja eigentlich, eigentlich daran kannst du es auch nicht mehr festmachen.
Deswegen machen die Anbieter heute solche Sachen wie Fingerprinting über Emojis zum Beispiel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so der letzte, der letzte Stand ist, ja, ich bin nicht im Browser-Fingerprinting-Game, aber zum Beispiel eine Sache ist, guckt euch das mal an, ich zeige euch mal ein Beispiel.
Sieht die Seite so kacke aus, ja, so, euch wird vielleicht auffallen.
Ja.
Okay, so, euch wird vielleicht auffallen, dass, warum sieht denn die Seite neuerdings so kacke aus, Alter?
Die hatten doch immer so eine Schriftarten-History.
Hier, genau, die Seite ist neu.
So, also euch wird vielleicht auffallen, dass Emojis je nach Plattform alle ein bisschen unterschiedlich aussehen.
Und dementsprechend machen Hersteller, oder beziehungsweise Hersteller-Anbieter, die euch tracken wollen, allerdings die euch nicht tracken können, aufgrund eurer Browser-Settings oder so.
Oder andere Maßnahmen, die ihr getroffen habt, versuchen irgendwie einen Fingerprint anzufertigen, also was euren Browser möglichst einzigartig macht.
Und eines der Tricks in der Vergangenheit war, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so State-of-the-Art ist, was Tracking angeht, aber ich könnte mir das vorstellen, war, man zeichnet in ein Canvas, Canvas ist ein HTML-Element, wo man Pixel selber malen kann, malt man Emojis rein.
Und daran erkennt man folgendes, du erkennst schon mal relativ sicher, welche Plattform der jeweilige User benutzt.
Weil, naja, wenn die Emojis so aussehen, ist er höchstwahrscheinlich auf irgendeinem Apple-Gerät.
Sehen die Emojis da aus, ist er wahrscheinlich auf einem Android.
Sehen die Emojis so aus, dann ist er wahrscheinlich auf einem Samsung und sowas.
Also ihr erkennt relativ gut, was der Typ für ein Gerät, eventuell auch schon, was er für einen Browser verwendet.
Und was ihr damit auch rauskriegt ist, wenn ihr diesen Test ein paar Mal durchführt,
ihr sogar, wie schnell der jeweilige Rechner ist, nämlich anhand dessen, wie schnell er und wie er dieses Emoji malt.
Ihr erkennt zum Beispiel auch an Schriftarten, welcher Font-Renderer verwendet wird
und dementsprechend könnt ihr Rückschlüsse ziehen aufs Betriebssystem und sowas.
Also an einem Publich-Offsite-gerenderten Emoji kannst du verdammt viel erkennen.
Und es gibt Tests, dass du rein mit JavaScript-Messungen rausfinden kannst, welche CPU relativ, relativ sicher,
welche CPU und welche Grafikkarte im Rechner verbaut ist.
So, dann hast du zumindest schon mal die Information, welchen Browser benutzt er, welche Grafikkarte hat er,
welche CPU hat er, welches Betriebssystem benutzt er.
Ja, da hast du schon mal recht gut Informationen gesammelt über deinen User,
ohne dass du ihn irgendwie mit diesen, mit den klassischen Tracking-Varianten überhaupt tracken,
noch tracken musst und kannst ihn trotzdem ganz gut zuordnen.
Also man bekommt sowas ganz gut raus.
Obwohl man das nicht so gut weiß.
Obwohl man Tracking-Anti-Tracking-Maßnahmen ergreift.
So, ich weiß nicht, wie wir drauf gekommen sind, aber wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt.
Ich guck mir nochmal die Questions kurz an aus dem Chat.
Ja, also wenn du wirklich anonym sein willst, dann ist Tor wahrscheinlich dein Best Bet.
Islam as fuck und natürlich auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher, wie man das sieht.
Mal gucken, welchen Exit-Node du verwendest.
Nicht unbedingt den von der CIA, wenn du komische Sachen treibst.
Wobei ich natürlich empfehlen würde, gar keine komischen Sachen erst im Internet zu treiben.
Lassen sich aus den Cookies auch nach dem Ablauf des Cookies die Daten zurückherstellen,
so dass ich meine Passwörter rekonstruieren kann?
Ja, du kannst das.
Bei der Webseite bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob die Webseite die noch lesen kann nach dem Ablauf.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, ob der Ablauf eine reine, wie soll ich sagen?
Kosmetik-Serie ist.
Sache ist, da habe ich mich nicht bisher mit beschäftigt,
eine Kosmetik-Sache ist, sodass
die Webseite sagen kann, es ist ausgelaufen
oder ob der Browser den
Cookie, nachdem er abgelaufen ist, gar nicht mehr
ausliefert.
Ich weiß es nicht. Du kannst auf jeden Fall,
solange du die Cookies hast, noch auslesen.
Wenn die denn in den Cookies überhaupt drinnen stehen.
Genau. Wollte ich gerade sagen, wenn die nämlich
nicht drinnen stehen, dann, tja, dann
auch nicht. Genau, wenn du nur deine Session-ID
drinnen hast, dann nicht.
Doch, hat man, habe ich ja gerade versucht zu erklären.
Ja, hat man. So, wir gucken jetzt das Video.
Fertig.
Ist randvoll mit externen
Trackern. Bing bekommt eure
Daten, also Microsoft, zu denen
Bing einfach gehört. Google
ist mit Google Analytics auch dabei.
Yahoo ist über Y-Image
dabei. Facebook ist auch
dabei. Also eigentlich kann jeder
was von euren Daten abhaben, auch wenn
ihr den Opera VPN benutzt.
Und das bei einem Browser,
inklusive VPN, der mit
Privacy wirbt. Dazu kommt übrigens
noch,
diese besonderen Add-ons,
die im Gaming-Browser drin sind,
wie Discord oder Twitch, sind
im Browser. Ja, die können natürlich
alles mitlesen. Das bedeutet, Opera kann theoretisch
alles mitlesen, was sie auf diesen Websites tut.
Das ist ein weiterer Grund, warum ich es nicht verwenden würde.
Das können sie nicht,
wenn ihr diese Websites extern habt.
Aber die große Frage ist,
was macht den Browser so viel schlimmer als
Chrome oder die anderen? Die Frage ist,
die sich mir eher stellt, ist, warum
hat dieser Browser überhaupt so viele
Benutzer? Ich habe es von Anfang an
nicht verstanden.
Warum das so viele benutzen? Wahrscheinlich
zieht wirklich die Werbung aus, weniger
RAM, schnellste und Gaming, ohne
dass die Leute, wenn sie es dann benutzen,
sich überlegen, ja, Moment,
ist es denn überhaupt wirklich so?
Die tracken
ja auch jede einzelne Website, die wir besuchen.
Im gruseligen technischen
Teil konnten wir jetzt feststellen, dass sich
Opera ein ziemlich gutes Bild von euch machen kann.
Und von eurem Profil, wer ihr seid,
welche YouTube-Videos ihr schaut, welche
Musik ihr hört, auf welche Pornos ihr steht,
und welche Dating-Websites ihr besucht.
Jetzt kommt es drauf an,
wem ihr eure Daten geben wollt.
Und das bestimmt die Firma dahinter.
Opera und Opera GX
werden entwickelt von
Opera Software, einer nordischen
Firma. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut,
denn in Europa... Das war mal
so, ja, die haben es aber an die China-Chinesen
verkauft. ... gilt die DSGVO.
Diese Firma und
Opera werben übrigens nicht gerade
wenig mit ihrer Geschichte und
dass sie das ja alles schon so lange machen.
Software made in Norway since
1995. Aber
eine Sache verschweigen sie dabei.
Opera war früher ganz vorne dabei
bei den dubiosen Marketing-
Konzepten. Habt ihr euch früher
zufällig auf zwielichtigen
Seiten rumgetrieben? Dann habt ihr vielleicht
gelegentlich mal Werbung für Java
Updates oder Video-
Abspiel-Software oder ähnliches bekommen.
Was ihr aber dann tatsächlich bekommen habt, wenn
ihr dieses Java Update installiert habt,
war Opera, der sich
einfach so als Standard-Browser
in euer System geschrieben hat,
obwohl ihr dacht, ihr habt ein Java Update
installiert. Habt ihr über
Chip Online eine Software installiert,
muss man immer höllisch aufpassen, nicht noch
zufällig andere Software zu installieren.
Auch da war sehr häufig
Opera dabei. Das nennt sich
Adware und ist eine Art
von unerwünschter Software.
Das ist also nicht gerade eine
rühmliche Geschichte, mit der sie sich da schmücken. Aber
die Firma ist an sich auch eine
andere, als sie vorgibt zu sein.
Opera Software, die norwegische
Firma, von der wir es gerade hatten, die Opera entwickelt,
gehört zu 100%
der Opera Group.
Und diese Opera Group wiederum
gehört zu 100%
einem chinesischen Konsortium.
Ein Konsortium ist ein Zusammenschluss
von eigentlich unabhängigen Firmen,
um ein gemeinsames Ziel zu verfolgen.
Das heißt, da stecken eben mehrere Firmen
dahinter. Klingt ja auch schon
sehr vertrauenserweckend,
oder? Das Golden Brick
Silk Road Equity Investment Fund.
Ja, da
mit denen will ich unbedingt alles schicken.
...ein gemeinsames Ziel zu verfolgen.
Das heißt, da stecken eben mehrere Firmen
dahinter. Die Firma, die aber hauptsächlich
drinsteckt, ist Beijing Kunlun Tech.
Ach die!
Fun Fact, es ist eh schwer informiert...
...über dieses Unternehmen zu bekommen.
Es gibt nicht mal einen Wikipedia-Eintrag
zu ihnen, nur für den Gründer.
Aber an der Börse.
Sie sind aber eher dafür bekannt,
einfach ausländische Apps aufzukaufen.
Sie haben einige mobile Games,
das musikbasierte Social Network
Star Group, aber vor allem
Opera gehören ihnen. Aber
unsere Daten, die wir Opera geben,
sollten ja eigentlich nur zur norwegischen
Opera-Software kommen, richtig?
Die Firma hat dann ja eigentlich nur was
von den Profiten, die aus dem Browser
entstehen, wo der Plan.
Dazu zitiere ich mal übersetzt
aus Operas Datenschutzerklärung.
Im Allgemeinen fungieren
die anderen Unternehmen der Opera-Gruppe,
die Zugang zu personenbezogenen
Daten haben können, als
Datenverarbeiter für Opera
Norwegen. Zitat Ende.
Das heißt, innerhalb der Opera
Group können alle
anderen Unternehmen auf die Daten
zugreifen. Das heißt, die Daten
landen eben doch bei Kunlun
Tech. Und das ist ein
Problem. Einige Beispiele, wie so
mal kurz hier. Kunlun
Tech besaß auch die App
Grindr, eine LGBT
Dating App. Eine Dating App ist
ziemlich sensibel. Sie
enthält nämlich Chats, Bilder und im
Fall von Grindr sogar gesundheitliche
Daten. Im April 2018
gab es Berichte darüber, Bilder,
das sind wahrscheinlich, weiß ich nicht,
wahrscheinlich zur Hälfte Dickpics, oder?
Das Grindr
den HIV-Status
seiner Nutzer an Dritte weitergegeben hat.
Das ist natürlich ein Ding, ja. Allein die Registrierung auf einer solchen
Plattform kann euch übrigens in manchen
Ländern das Leben kosten. Sollte Kunlun
Tech hier die Informationen beispielsweise
an Länder weitergeben, in denen Homosexualität
illegal ist,
ist das weniger lustig für euch,
weil es hier am Fall steht. Deswegen hat
die US-amerikanische Regierung so
lange Druck ausgeübt, bis Kunlun
Tech seine Anteile verkauft hat.
Die USA begründen es mit
nationaler Sicherheit und ihr wisst, wie
unangenehm die bei dem Thema sind.
Aber auch die Opera Group
selbst ist nicht ganz rein
von solchen Problemen. Opera hat
nämlich auch einige Kredit-Apps,
also Apps, wo ihr euch Geld leihen
könnt. Ein Bericht von
Hindenburg Research behauptet, dass
einige dieser Kredit-Apps
Räuberisches Verhalten zeigen und
damit gegen die Google Play Store Richtlinien
verstoßen. Die Apps, die in Frage gestellt
werden, sind Ocash und
Opesa in Kenien,
Opay in Nigeria und
Cashbean in Indien.
Räuberisches Verhalten klingt so übel,
wie es wirklich ist. Opesa
beispielsweise bietet laut Bericht
einen Kredit für 91-365
Tage und 12%
maximalem jährlichen
Zinssatz. Zumindest
sagen sie das. Der Bericht sagt,
in Wahrheit geht der Kredit
15 Tage und der jährliche
Zins ist bei 438%.
Wir werden es übrigens sogar
876%. Also
stellt euch vor, ihr leiht euch 100 Euro,
weil es mal knapp ist und geht davon aus,
dass ihr in einem Jahr 112
Euro zurückzahlen müsst.
In Wahrheit müsst ihr dann aber
876 Euro zurückzahlen,
weil das Marketing
euch falsch informiert hat.
Das ist durchaus
räuberisches Verhalten. Deswegen hat
Google diese Apps kurzerhand aus dem
App Store geschmissen. Klar, in Nigeria,
Kenia und Indien ist jetzt
der Käuferschutz nicht so hoch wie bei uns.
Da können sich die Leier
nicht so richtig gegen sowas wehren.
Und was man nie vergessen darf,
auch mit dem neuen Datenschutzgesetz
in China darf der chinesische
Staat noch immer zu
100% auf alle Daten
der Unternehmen zugreifen.
Also auch auf alle Daten von
euch bei Kunlun Tech.
An der Stelle erinnere ich noch mal ganz gerne,
dass Minderheiten wie die Uiguren
dort verfolgt werden und unabhängiger
Journalismus fast unmöglich ist.
China ist Platz
179 von
180 in der Rangliste der Pressefreiheit.
Wo sind wir?
Wir sind bestimmt auch nicht mehr ganz oben.
Ich habe letztens irgendeine Statistik.
Ich glaube, wir sind auf 10 oder so.
Es gibt zudem ein Social Scoring,
zu dem ich mal ein Video erstellt habe.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr wollt,
dass ein solcher Staat weiß,
was für eine Person ihr seid.
Also, ich fasse nochmal zusammen.
Opera und Opera GX sind Spyware
und damit eine Form von Malware.
Opera wird zwar in Norwegen
entwickelt, gehört aber zu 100%
einer chinesischen Firma.
Opera erhält Zugriff auf
alle eure besuchten Websites.
Der VPN und die Apps machen es
eher schlimmer als besser.
Die iOS-Apps wurden schon aus dem Playstore geworfen,
wegen räuberischem Verhalten.
Und der chinesische Staat,
der eine Reihe von Menschenrechtsverletzungen
quasi täglich begeht,
hat ebenfalls vollständigen Zugriff.
Das heißt für mich,
Opera und Opera GX
sollte man nicht unterstützen.
Im Gegenteil.
So im Detail war es mir nicht klar,
aber ich wusste, dass ich es nie verwenden will,
weil ich mir
das schon gedacht habe.
Ich habe kein Opera mehr verwendet,
seitdem die Chinesen
verkauft haben.
Opera zu benutzen,
sei besser als Chrome,
dem kann ich auch nicht mehr helfen.
Chrome ist auch nicht gut,
aber dazu habe ich ja schon einen Browser-Vergleich erstellt.
Um nun eurem Datenschutz ein wenig
auf die Sprünge zu helfen,
wir gucken mal kurz rein.
Rangliste der Pressefreiheit.
Was haben wir denn hier so?
Bei uns geht es noch ganz okay.
Den Rest kannst du vergessen.
Also, wen haben wir denn hier?
Norwegen, Irland,
Dänemark, Skandinavia,
Litauen, Estland, Portugal.
Wo sind wir?
Wir sind eine ganze Ecke
hinter Norwegen.
Norwegen hat 95 Punkte,
was auch immer das genau ist.
Und wir haben nur
81 Punkte.
Und jetzt lasst uns doch mal gucken,
wer hier unten so am Start ist.
Natürlich
die China-Chinesen.
Und wer hätte das gedacht?
Auf dem letzten Platz natürlich
Nordkorea.
Damit habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch schon gerechnet,
dass das doch unten drunter ist.
Aber, guck, gar nicht so viel unten drunter.
Gar nicht so viel unten drunter.
Das sind ja alles hier, allemal Länder,
alles zusammen Länder, wo man eigentlich nicht hin will.
Wo ist denn Dubai,
wo die ganzen...
Zu was gehört denn Dubai?
Äh...
Dubai...
Ja.
Emirates.
Da wo die ganzen Influencer
am Start sind,
die sind jetzt
auch nicht so geil.
Und wenn die mitkriegen, dass du bei Grindr
registriert bist, finden die das bestimmt auch nicht so toll.
Weil ich gehe mal ganz stark,
also ich weiß es nicht, aber ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus,
dass es schwul oder lesbisch sein
dort bestimmt auch verboten ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gleich gesteinigt oder sowas.
Also da muss man echt drauf aufpassen.
Das klingt immer so
lapidar, so Datenschutz ist wichtig.
Ähm...
Wir spüren halt selten die richtig krass negativen
Auswirkungen davon.
Da muss ich da wirklich Gedanken zu machen.
Also muss ich da wirklich mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Und man kann einfach auf
Opera GX verzichten.
Opera GX kann nix besser als andere Browser.
Tja...
Ne, jetzt nicht. Wir fahren das nächste Mal
mit ihm nach Berlin.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger. Kein Lachs mit Nudeln.
Heute Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
RGB 120 FPS Browser.
Das ist halt auch so...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die werben mit 120 FPS.
Aber dein Browser
wird sich wahrscheinlich ziemlich
ziemlich stark nach deiner
Display Refresh Rate
richten.
Und sollte Chrome
oder sollte
Plink heißt doch jetzt unter der Haube
die ganze Zeugchen Chrome
das unterstützen, dann kann das Chrome
auch. Zu Recht ja, ne?
Klingt wie ein typischer
Fall, warum man in diesem Ranking
runtergestuft werden sollte.
Chatge, ich geh
jetzt essen. Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn. Vielleicht spielen wir heute weiter Baldur's Gate 3
heute Nachmittag.
Bis denn, macht's gut. See you!